This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一档由I-Heart制作的播客，真人保证。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难成长的历程》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）。这个节目探讨黑人男性的生活经历，进行那些在别处实在不安全、不敢进行的坦诚对话，而你正在与一位知晓自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲，它向全世界释放出一种信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就必须得这么做。请在I-Heart电台应用、苹果播客或各大播客平台上收听《艰难成长的历程》。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。那是数字2%。
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%
在I-Heart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们约会过的竟然是同一个劣迹斑斑的世纪骗子时，她们决定亲自动手讨回公道。
on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands.
我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的报酬。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。请在I-Heart电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听
I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
《相信我，宝贝》（Trust Me, Babe）。大家好，欢迎再次回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），在这个播客里，我们探讨二十多岁时经历的一些重大变化和人生转折，以及它们对我们心理的意义。艾格斯（Eggs）刚刚放了个屁，大家，所以我们要休息五分钟。大家好，欢迎回到本期播客。感谢大家的收听。这是一期非常特殊的节目。今天，这是《闺蜜闲聊》（Girl Talk）的有史以来第一期节目，因为我们请到了三位非常特别的嘉宾。大家好。嗨。Guten Tag。（德语：你好）
podcast. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Eggs just farted everyone, so we're going to take a quick five-minute break. Hello and welcome back to the podcast. Thanks for tuning in. We have a very special episode. So today, it's the first ever episode of Girl Talk, because we have three very special guests. Hello, everyone. Hi. Good and talk.
Guten Tag。是的，我请来了三位特别的嘉宾，也就是我的几个密友。在进入《闺蜜闲聊》之前，我们先做一个简短的自我介绍。艾琳（Erin），我正看着你呢。我先来？当然是你。你好。我叫艾琳。
Good and tug. Yeah, I brought on some three special guests, some close friends of mine. We'd like to do a little mini introduction before we get into the Girl Talk. Erin, I'm looking at you. I go first. Of course you do. Hello. My name is Erin.
我以前上过这个播客。你做的是哪期节目？我很久以前做过“朝九晚五”那一期。对，那是我们有史以来最早的几期节目之一。伙计们，你们知道这播客快满一年了吗？这挺让人印象深刻的。快满一年了。真的吗？
I've been on the podcast before. What was the episode that you did? I did the 9 to 5 episode a long time ago. Yeah, it was one of our first ever episodes. Guys, you know it's almost a year of the podcast? That's pretty impressive. It's coming up to a year. Really?
哪一天？6月5日。所以我确实期待第一个生日礼物。不，你想想，我们为我和播客办一个联合生日派对。听起来好悲哀啊。不，我喜欢。我喜欢。不太悲哀。
What day? On the 5th of June. So I do expect first birthday presents. No, think about it. We have a combined birthday party for me and the podcast. That sounds so sad. No, I love it. I love it. Not so sad.
不。我今年不想过生日，所以我们要把它变成关于播客的派对。好的。因为我听得太多了，以至于我几乎……你确实也收到了……我是个投资人。艾琳？好吧，等等。对于本播客的忠实听众来说，艾琳确实得到了不少公开感谢。我确实有。我确实有。是的。所以，现在她活生生地坐在这里。
No. I don't want to have a birthday this year, so we'll make it about the podcast instead. Okay. Because I listen to it so much that I'm practically... And you do receive... I'm an investor. Eric? Okay, wait. For the frequent listeners of the podcast, Erin does actually receive quite a few shoutouts. I do. I do. Yeah. So, now she's in here in the flesh.
抛开艾琳不谈，我们还有播客的另一位朋友，节目的另一位朋友在这里。梅格（Meg）。我叫梅格。我有梅格。是梅格。我在播客里出场过。那是和马迪（Maddie）一起关于哈佛的。牛津。哦，抱歉。拜拜。
And Aaron aside, we have another friend of the podcast, another friend of the show here. Meg. My name's Meg. I have Meg. It's Meg. I have featured on the podcast. It was with Maddie about a Harvard. Oxford. Oh, sorry. Bye-bye.
回答错误。你甚至都上过那一期节目，却连细节都记不住。我知道那是牛津还是哈佛。不过那也是一段时间以前的事了。对，那是很久以前了。我可以说大概是九个月前吧。那是在堪培拉封城之前。对。
Wrong answer. You were even on the episode, and you can't even remember the detail. I knew it was Oxford or Harvard. It was also a while ago, though. Yeah, it was a while ago. It was probably nine months ago, I'd say. It was before lockdown in Canberra. Yeah.
不管怎样，嗯，对，我叫梅格，我们今天都在海岸聚齐了。我们聚在那里。谢谢你，梅格。本期非常特殊的《闺蜜闲聊》的最后一位嘉宾。嗨，我是E.J.。E.J.是一个播客新手。播客新手。
Anyway, um, yeah, my name is Meg, and we are all gathered at the coast today. We gathered this there. Thank you, Meg. And our final guest of this very special episode of Girls Talk. Hi, I'm E.J. E.J. A podcast virgin. Podcast virgin.
是的，第一次。非常兴奋能打破僵局。打破僵局。抱歉。打破僵局。你知道，还有什么说法吗？破处。破处。
Yeah, first time. Very excited to break the seal. Break the seal. Sorry. Break the seal. You know, what's a high room? Pop the cherry. Pop the cherry.
破处。E.J.也还没太意识到，在录播客时，你其实得坐得离麦克风近一点。抱歉。没，没关系。把麦克风拉近E.J.。嗯，我刚才正想这么做呢。我们已经把麦克风掉进薯片碗里了。
Pop the cherry. EJ also hasn't quite realized that on the podcast, do you actually have to sit kind of close to the mic. Sorry. It's, no, it's totally fine. the mic closer to E.J. Well, I was trying to do that. We have already dropped the mic in the bowl of the chips.
我在想……我有一根棍子。也许吧。什么？一根用来，你知道的。哦，对。哦，比如把手机绑在上面。对。
I was thinking of... I have a stick. Maybe. Pardon? A stick to, you know. Oh, yeah. Oh, like, tape the phone. Yeah.
我们应该把手机绑在棍子上吗？是的。好吧。我们会搞定的。这是一个进化中的好主意。就像自拍杆一样，不过是用在播客上。对。你脑子里冒出这个是因为我们在后面生了火吗？
We should tape the phone to a stick? Yes. Okay. We'll get to that. It's that's an evolutionary idea. Like a selfie stick, but for the podcast. Yeah. Did that come to mind because we have the fire going in the back?
不，我觉得麦克风就……但我也想到了引火柴。木棍房子。对，我们实际上大概可以那样做。所以，嗯，欢迎E.J.。第一次来，让我们大家一起给E.J.一个热烈的欢迎。噢！谢谢大家。你很激动吗？
No, I felt like a microphone. Just pl... But I also thought of a kindling. stick house. Yeah, we could actually probably do that. So, um, welcome EJ. First time, let's all give EJ a warm welcome. Woo! Thanks everyone. Are you excited?
对，我很期待。有点微醺的感觉，但我很期待。对，我想我们都有点微醺。你为什么看着我？我没看。嗯，那，那一阵笑声就暴露了。别这样。我们其实都有点微醺。对于我们今天的播客，我想让你们想象一下我们正在出汗的情景。
Yeah, I'm keen. A little buzz, but I'm keen. Yeah, we're all a little buzzed, I think. Why did you look at me? I didn't look at it. Um, that, that laughing audio right there gives it away. Don't do this. We're a little bit buzz to do. To our podcast today, I would like you to picture us sweating.
因为杰玛（Gemma）生了一场漂亮的火。嘿，我在那场火上干得真不错。正因如此，我们在出汗，而且我们开着窗户。我们开着门。我们穿着泳衣，对吧？我们穿着泳衣。梅格刚才有点半裸。我不得不去换衣服。
Because we have a beautiful fire created by Gemma. Hey, I did a really good job on that fire. And because of that, we are sweating and we have windows open. We have doors open. We've got bathers on, haven't we? We got bathers on. Meg went a little bit nudie before. I had to get changed.
换上了她那件超级性感的内衣。不，我只是说，它真的很可爱。我当时在欣赏它。我们可没有在打任何品牌广告。没有，但那是什么牌子？没牌子。上面只绣了一只戴着胸甲的独角兽。
Into her really sexy underwear. No, I just say, it was really cute. I was admiring it. We're not advertising any brands. No, but what was the brand? No brand. It just has a unicorn. in a chestplate.
确实有。而且它美极了。所以我们生了火。E.J.，也许你可以告诉听众们，我们今天为什么都聚在这里？我们都住在不同的城市。那么是什么原因让我们今天都聚在这里呢？我们真的很需要休息一下。
It does. And it was gorgeous. So we got the fire going. E.J., maybe you can tell the listeners, why are we all gathered here today? We all live in different cities. So what has made it that we're all here today? We really needed a break.
我们真的很需要一个假期。所以我们都聚在了一起。这就是为什么我们在海岸。所以我们在海岸，对。哪个海岸？杰维斯湾（Jarvis Bay）附近？对。对。
We really needed a vacation. So we all came together. And that's why we're at the coast. So we're at the coast, yeah. Which coast? Near Jarvis Bay? Yes. Yeah.
米尔顿（Milton）。米尔顿？对，我们在米尔顿。这到底是怎么……有人没把手机调成静音。难道不是这边的人吗？别说我把手机调成静音了。哦，我调了。
Milton. Milton? Yeah, we're Milton. And how did this all... Someone didn't put their phone on silent. Didn't someone on this side? Give me shit having my phone silent. Oh, I did.
好吧，作为背景交代，再次说明，E.J.今天大概把手机丢了五次。其中有一次，她把手机放在一个加油站的车顶上，然后车就开动了。对，所以基本上我们都觉得需要休息，于是我们决定去海边。对。对。所以我和E.J.
Okay, for context, again, EJ lost her phone about five times today. One of these times she left her phone on top of the car in a petrol station and the car was moving. Yeah, so basically we all needed a break and we decided that we should go to the coast. Yeah. Yeah. So me and E.J.
从悉尼开车下来。艾琳是从堪培拉开过来的。我们待会儿会聊到这个。梅格，你是从哪儿开过来的？从斯威夫特克里克（Swift's Creek）。斯威夫特克里克。在维多利亚州。是的，完全正确。
drove down from Sydney. Aaron drove from Canberra. We'll get to that. And Meg, what did you drive from? From Swift's Creek. Swift's Creek. In Victoria. Yes, exactly.
谢谢。不是瑞士那个国家。瑞士军刀？对。不，是的。昨天从那儿开车过来的。我们都到了这儿，度过了非常美好的一天。我们觉得怎么样？
Thank you. Not Swiss as in the country. Swiss Army now? Yeah. No, yes. Drove from there yesterday. And we all got here and we've had a really lovely day. What would we say?
对，这里很美。天气好得不得了。我们的车确实出了点小事故。哦，对。有人想解释一下当时发生了什么吗？艾琳。艾琳，我的车怎么了？当然是，我马上要，等等，简单说一下，
Yeah, it's beautiful. Most beautiful weather. We did have an incident with the car. Oh, yes. Would anyone like to explain what happened there? Erin. Erin, what happened with my car? And of course it was, I'm just going to, wait, just quickly,
那是我的车，因为我平时根本不爱保养车。杰玛自去年12月以来就没给轮胎充过气。我们现在已经是五月了。六个月。六个月。亲爱的听众，嗯，是的，所以轮胎情况不太妙。希望它们没有漏气。
it was my car because I do not take care of my car. Gemma had not pumped her ties up since December. We are now in May. Six months. Six months. Dear listener, Um, and yes, so the tires were not doing well. Hopefully they're not punctured.
我觉得没漏气。我只是觉得你一直没给它们充气。好吧，这个路人，我们本想去一家二手慈善店，结果关门了。真遗憾。不幸的是。我们当时在，E.J.，你觉得那是什么地方？二手店旁边那个两元店。对。
I don't think they're punctured. I just don't think you pumped them up. Well, this random guy, we were trying to go to this op shop and it was closed. Sadly. Unfortunately. And we were in this, what would you describe it as, EJ? The $2 shop next to the op shop. Yeah.
那真是个宝藏地方。我们当时想，天哪，我们有临时纹身！哦，我有个临时纹身！好吧，等等，等等。抱歉。抱歉。别扯那个了。一个播客。
It was a true. We were like, oh my God, we have temporary tattoos. Oh, I've got a temporary tattoos. Okay, wait, wait. Sorry. Sorry. I don't get into it. A podcast.
你有个播客。你有个播客。我想我们也许应该把话说完。伙计们，艾琳刚才差点真的跑……我是认真的。我想投入进去。注意力高度集中应该放在一个……不，放在播客上。哦，放在……
You have a podcast. You have podcast. I think maybe we should finish this. Guys, Erin almost literally ran... I do. I want to commit. A hyperfixation needs to be on one... No, to the podcast. Oh, to the...
哦，放在播客上。哦，等等，等等。所以，我们基本上……等等，等等，等等，等等。所以我们……让我们把这一段重温一下。我们去了……我们试图去那家Vinnie's慈善店。
Oh, to the podcast. Oh, wait, wait. So, we basically... Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. So we... Let's just do a little bit of a refresh year. We went... We tried to go to this Vinnie's.
我们最后去了那里。关门了。所以我们去了这家两元店，E.J.买了一些临时纹身。艾琳刚才直接从座位上跳起来，跑去弄那些纹身了。它们太可爱了。它们真的很可爱，但我们现在也确实正在录音。
We ended up going there. It was closed. So we went to this $2 shop and E.J. has bought temporary tattoos. Erin literally just leaped out of her seat, then, to go and do them. They're so cute. They are really cute, but we're also literally recording right now.
我觉得这可以是一个有趣的周边活动。但播客听众没法跟着玩。他们只能听我们给彼此贴临时纹身。去一家两元店，发现了非常可爱的临时纹身，还买了一件经营这家店的女士亲手织的毛衣。因为她是一个非常厉害的钩针编织艺术家。对，所以基本上这位女士人非常好，
I thought it could be a fun side activity. But the podcast listeners can't play along. They just have to listen to us, give each other temporary. Go to a $2 tattoo tattoo. To do a $2 shop, finds him really cute temporary tattoos and buy a sweater handmade by the lady who runs a shop. Because she's a really good crochet artist. Yeah, well, so basically this lady was really nice,
她，就好像是亲手钩织了所有这些毛衣。这完全是个题外话，但我们当时在那家店里，然后这个随机的家伙走到我跟前说，你觉得怎么样，当时他说了什么？你还记得吗？不好意思。
and she was, like, hand crocheted all these sweaters. and this is a real sidebar but we were in this store and then this random guy came up to me and was like, how would you was just, what did he say? Do you remember? Excuse me.
你的左手轮胎。右手。不，不，但他先说是左手，然后他纠正了自己。然后他说，哦，我指的是右后轮胎有点瘪了，接着杰玛就出去检查了。
Your left hand tires. Right hand. No, no, but he said left hand and then he corrected himself. And then he said, oh, I meant the right hand tire is a bit flat and then Gemma went out to inspect it.
我确实出去检查了。我当时穿着一件奇怪的、像钩针编织的比基尼上衣。但那位女士人很好，说你应该试穿一下。然后这个男人走进来，说你们的轮胎撒气了，我说，哦。哦，好的。但他却说，你的轮胎看起来你该去检查一下了。而我们当时正处于鸟不拉屎的荒郊野岭。就像是个极小的小镇。
I did go out to inspect it. And I had like a weird like crochet bikini top on. But like the lady was like you should try it on. And then this man came in was like your tires deflated and I was like, oh. Oh good. But he was like your tires, it looks like you should get that checked out. And we were like in the middle of but fuck nowhere. Like this is like some tiny town.
华拉华拉，瓦拉。这里是卡拉拉湾（Kalala Bay），各位。我们在卡拉拉湾，亲爱的听众。我们在卡拉拉湾，亲爱的听众。我们在卡拉拉湾。卡拉拉湾，那里简直就像是Vinnie's炸鸡店。那里好像有个RGA，
Walla, Walla, Walah. It's Kalala Bay, everyone. We were in Kalala Bay, dear listener. We were in Kalala Bay, dear listener. We were in Kalala Bay. Lalibay and it was literally like Vinnie's chicken shop There was an RGA there
我猜，然后还有这个奇怪的两元店。你知道吗？不管怎样，在特拉诺瓦（Teranova）之前，抱歉，扯远了。每个人表现得都不太好。艾琳！我想听听梅格的
I guess and then there was this weird $2 store What did you know? Before Teranova anyway Sorry, sidetracked Everyone is not being great Erin! I want to hear about Meg's
特拉诺瓦经历。我不知道，我怎么会有那种经历？对，我跟你说过。我只是没意识到那就是那个地方。你要说
Terranova experience I don't know how did I have it? Yeah, I've told you about it I just didn't realize that was where it was You're gonna say No, okay Maybe we'll cut that bit out I don't think we're going to
不，好吧。也许我们会把那段剪掉。我不觉得我们会剪掉。这是一期真实的节目，我们在展现高度的真实性。这叫《闺蜜闲聊》，宝贝。这就是女孩们会做的事。我们聊天。我们聊天。
this is an authentic episode and we're being highly authentic here. It's called Girl Talk, babe. This is what girls do. We talk. We talk. And we paint our mouths and we get temporary tattoos and buffer flies. I mean, Erin is like really on a scat moment right here. She's like, you cannot keep focus.
我们在嘴唇上涂画，我们贴临时纹身和蝴蝶。我的意思是，艾琳现在真的是思绪乱飞。她就像是，你根本无法集中注意力。
I've had the flu all weekend, by the way, everybody. And I'm sweating because I don't know whether it's the pot or don't know where this is hot. I'm sweating. It's really hot. It's very warm. So maybe we should move on to this question that we had. How are we all doing? Aaron, are you...
顺便说一句，各位，我整个周末都得了流感。我在出汗，因为我不知道是因为炉子还是因为这里很热。我在出汗。真的很热。非常暖和。所以也许我们应该转到我们刚才提出的那个问题上来。我们大家都过得怎么样？艾琳，你……
I think I've done a good job of explaining how I'm going. I've got the flu. I've got the terrible camera flu. And what's it be? Somebody said... Oh, there's like this name for it that somebody used the other day.
我觉得我已经很好地解释了我的近况。我得了流感。我得了可怕的摄像头流感。那叫什么来着？有人说……哦，前几天有人用过一个专门的名字来称呼它。
Super flu. Super flu. No, it was like... Influenza A. I'm not. Swine flu. No, it was like this horrible like...
超级流感。超级流感。不，就像是……甲型流感。我没有。猪流感。不，就像那种可怕的……
No, Tuesday flu sentence that was like... Swin flu. It's the like... It's the like... Um, Anyway, I have the flu and I'm being a little baby about it. I don't know if I haven't been coping very well.
不，周二流感那句话就像是……猪流感。就像是……就像是……嗯，不管怎样，我得了流感，而且我对此表现得像个小婴儿一样娇气。我不知道我是否应对得很好。
But I also haven't been feeling very well. It's worse than COVID. 110%. So, yeah. Wait, I thought of a joke. Yeah. Swine flu. I can't.
但我也确实感觉很不舒服。这比新冠还糟糕。110%糟糕。所以，是的。等等，我想到了一个笑话。对。猪流感。我真的不行了。
Swine flu walked so coronavirus could run. My God. I just totally laughed. I thought that was so funny. I mean, I don't know. I think COVID humor is still, unfortunately. quite more. Sorry, we've got to
猪流感打了个前锋，新冠才能一路狂奔。天哪。我刚才彻底笑喷了。我觉得这太搞笑了。我的意思是，我不知道。我觉得新冠幽默不幸的是，仍然……抱歉，我们得
basically try to put, we're in this little cabin and I sit, we put this fire on and it's so hot. And it's right opposite to where we're sitting. Like we're sitting very close. Yeah, it's like burning us. It's very warm. It died. It's really fucking hot.
基本上试着把，我们在这个小木屋里，我坐着，我们生了这堆火，里面太热了。而且它就正对着我们坐的地方。就像我们坐得很近一样。对，它简直要把我们烤焦了。非常暖和。火灭了。真他妈热。
Oh, no, and now we've broken it. Pull. Oh, there you go. Oh, no, no, other way, other way. There you go. Meg has broken the fireplace. And our Airbnb host is this old lady. The window is wide open.
哦，不，现在我们把它弄坏了。拉。哦，好了。哦，不，不，反方向，反方向。好了。梅格把壁炉弄坏了。而我们的爱彼迎（Airbnb）房东是个老太太。窗户开得大大的。
Oh. Hi. But she's like this old grandma and she's really, really sweet. She's really, really sweet. The house is like 300 meters from where we are sitting. Yeah. It's quite close. And they're chicken.
哦。嗨。但她就像个老奶奶一样，真的，真的很甜美。她真的很甜美。房子距离我们坐的地方大约有300米。对。挺近的。而且有鸡。
There's a rooster. It's sexually assaulting. Every single fucking hen out there. I actually was so traumatized today. Don't even start me. How am I going? not very well. Like, E.J.
还有一只公鸡。正在性侵犯。外面的每一只该死的母鸡。我今天其实受了极大的精神创伤。甚至都别跟我提这事。我过得怎么样？不太好。就像，E.J.
You're up. Traumatized because we have these, basically at this Airbnb, there are all these chickens. There are all these chickens. There are all these chickens that are running around. And there's this one, free range. Very cute, but they're like,
轮到你了。受到创伤，因为我们有这些，基本上在这个爱彼迎里，到处都是鸡。到处都是鸡。到处都是鸡在跑来跑去。还有一只，散养的。很可爱，但它们总是，
try and eat out pancakes. And then there's this one rooster and it's like fully going at it with all the chickens. Waking us up. Waking us up firstly. At 5 a.m. 5 a.m. With disgusting crow.
试图吃我们的煎饼。然后还有这只公鸡，它完全是在和所有的母鸡胡搞。把我们吵醒。首先把我们吵醒。早上5点。早上5点。用恶心的啼叫声。
Yeah. And um... How that girl, Aaron? Yeah, what was that? Yeah, that wasn't great. So EJ is slightly traumatised. Meg, how are you going? Um, I'm actually doing great.
对。还有……那个女孩怎么样，艾琳？对，那是什么？对，那可不太好。所以E.J.有点心理创伤。梅格，你过得怎么样？嗯，我其实过得很好。
I am a bit, I think, not low, but a bit tired. I think maybe I did get the flu shot yesterday. Or I could you be just tired from the driving? But apart from that, I'm feeling good. They do six hours to be here with us. But I'm here now for five days. Anyway Wait, for five days
我觉得我有点，不是情绪低落，但有点累。我想也许我昨天确实打了流感疫苗。或者我也可能只是开车累了？但除此之外，我感觉很好。她们开了六个小时的车才来到这里陪我们。但我现在要在待上五天。等等，待五天？
No, around the East South Wales Oh, you're coming back to Canberra Yeah And how are you, Jenna? Uh I'm doing great guys I'm fine I've been better, I've been worse
不，在新南威尔士州周边。哦，你要回堪培拉了。对。你呢，杰玛？呃，我过得很好，伙计们。我挺好的。有过更好的时候，也有过糟糕的时候。
I think I'm a bit I've had a few glasses of the line Do I really want to divulge all my secrets? No, that's here Probably not But we did make Meg explain How dogs have sex On the podcast
我想我有点……我喝了几杯酒。我真的想把我的所有秘密都倾倒出来吗？不，就在这儿。可能不想。但我们确实让梅格解释了狗是如何交配的。在播客里。
People need to know yeah yeah fine lots of people buy puppies so they've got to know how it's been conceived oh that's true oh my god I thought that was I think that's absolutely hilarious but I think I'm doing I'm doing okay I'm like bit lonely bit sad at the moment are you with us yeah and so I'm feeling really the chip ball hit again if you're wearing headphones I'm sorry sorry but anyway so I'm doing well Erin's doing okay she's sick EJ's been traumatized by the chickens having sex. Meg is good.
人们需要知道，对，对，好吧，很多人买小狗，所以他们必须知道它是怎么孕育出来的。哦，那是真的。哦，天哪。我觉得那太……我觉得这绝对太搞笑了。但我觉得自己还好，我目前有点孤独，有点难过。你们在听吗？对，所以感觉真的……薯片碗又被撞到了。如果你戴着耳机，我很抱歉，抱歉。但不管怎样，我过得不错，艾琳过得还行，她生病了。E.J.被鸡交配的场景吓到了。梅格很好。
Satisfactory. Satisfactory. A bit tired. A bit tired because she got the flu shot. Yeah. I feel like that's a great introduction. Yeah. That's a really good introduction.
令人满意。令人满意。有点累。有点累，因为她打了流感疫苗。对。我觉得这是一个很棒的开场白。对。这真是一个很好的开场白。
So the plan with these chit-chat episodes, this one being the first, is a much more unstructured kind of conversation amongst friends. What do we think about this? Erin, any ideas? Meg, how do you feel? I don't mind it, but I just think they do need a little bit of structure, otherwise it just drags on. Yeah.
所以这些闲聊播客的计划，这期是第一期，将是朋友之间更无拘无束的一种对话。大家觉得怎么样？艾琳，有什么想法吗？梅格，你觉得呢？我不介意，但我只是觉得它们确实需要一点结构，否则就会变得太拖沓。对。
Yeah. We have structure. Yeah, so small tangent, that may only not have already been recorded and lost to the bowels of time. The boughs of time. Bows of EJ. Yeah, guys, we had to take a quick break because EJ has to go outside and fart. I'm sorry.
对。我们有结构。对，顺便插一句，刚才那段可能还没被录下来，就已经消逝在时间的长河里了。时间的长河。E.J.的长河。对，伙计们，我们不得不休息一下，因为E.J.得去外面放个屁。我很抱歉。
The Bows of E.J. Is the fact that Jack, my partner, doesn't like chit-chat podcast, and you don't either, Jem. I know this is a fact because I've tried to get you to listen to them before now, and you get so bored of the conversation, you skip them all. So he doesn't like it because he wants to, like, be a part of the conversation, so he doesn't like the fact that he's listening to their conversation, and he's not part of it, and he doesn't know the people. who are talking. So I find the podcast really fun to listen to when I know the people that
E.J.的长河。事实上，杰克（Jack），我的伴侣，不喜欢闲聊类的播客，你也不喜欢，杰姆。我知道这是事实，因为我以前曾试图让你听过，而你对这种对话感到如此厌烦，把它们全跳过了。所以他不喜欢，是因为他想，呃，成为对话的一部分，所以他不喜欢听他们的对话，而自己又不是其中一部分，也不认识那些说话的人。所以我发现，只有当我认识那些在闲聊的人时，听播客才会觉得很有趣，因为我了解他们的故事和背景。但是，嗯，如果你不认识我们，你就会觉得……所以如果你不认识我们，可能就没那么有娱乐性。但为了解决这个问题，我们挺搞笑的。我们挺搞笑的。而且，这也是PJ的长河。E.J.的长河特别在于……嗯，我们挺搞笑的。而且它会有结构。所以我们会回答一些关于生活的好问题。不会只是我们东拉西扯，因为我前几天听了一个糟糕的播客。我的。我的播客。
are chit-chatting because I know their story and I know their background. But, um, so if you don't know us, you're feeling, so if you don't know us, it's probably not that entertaining. But to solve that, we're pretty funny. We're pretty funny. And also, it's a bouts of PJ. The bowels of EJ is particularly. Um, we're pretty funny. And also it's going to be structured. So we will be answering interesting questions about life. It will not just be us rambling because I listened to a terrible one the other day. Mine. My podcast.
不，不是你的。哦，天哪。我绝不会对《你二十岁的心理学》说这种话。哦，那是我的播客。那就是那种类型的播客。不，因为我，如你所知，是一个忠实的听众。但我听了，对，我前几天听了一个，人们只是在谈论，比如他们的周末，以及他们对他们认识的某个女孩的看法。
No, not yours. Oh my God. I would never say such a thing about psychology of your 20s. Oh, that's my podcast. That was a sort of what it was called. No, because I, as you know, I'm a devout listener. But I listen, yeah, I listened to one the other day and people just talking about, like, their weekends and how they felt about, like, some girl that they knew.
然后我就想，我们能不这样吗，求你了？我们觉得E.J.怎么样？我喜欢那样。我喜欢精彩的闲聊。你喜欢。我喜欢精彩的闲聊。有趣。
And I was like, can we not do this, please? How do we feel about E. E.J. I love that. I love a good shit. You love it. I love a good chit-chat. Interesting.
我听了一个20分钟的播客，内容是他们为什么不喜欢Zara。我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我——我闻起来不太好。这期节目更多是为了我们自己，为了我们能在五年后回想起这段时光。回到这个小木屋。回到这个有着该死的高温壁炉的小木屋。当你拥有百万订阅者时。
I listened to a 20-minute podcast about why they didn't like Zara. And I-that's-throft doing that. Because that's, like, actually something of substance. No, because, no, because it was about, like, midlife crisis. And then they spent 20 minutes talking about going into Zara and how they didn't like how it looked like. Oh, my God. And I really enjoyed that. I thought I'm quite their beauty.
我听了一个20分钟的播客，讲的是他们为什么不喜欢Zara。我——这就是在瞎胡闹。因为这其实是有实质内容的东西。不对，因为，不对，因为它讲的是，比如说，中年危机。然后他们花了20分钟谈论走进Zara，以及他们多么不喜欢它看起来的样子。哦，天哪。我真的很喜欢那个。我觉得我挺中意他们的审美的。
Are you talking about the recent goes-out-s-out-saying podcast? Oh, my God, yeah. Yeah, I literally listen. I need to shout out. Not to shout out. I'm not even, I know. I know that. I listened to that episode
你是在说最近那个《goes-out-s-out-saying》播客吗？哦，天哪，对。对，我真的听了。我要喊话一下。不是要喊话。我甚至都不是，我知道。我知道那个。我听了那一集
I loved that. I like, literally like two days ago. Excuse me. Anyway. Please do not promote other podcasts on my podcast. Do not go and watch, listen to that podcast. We're not. What was it again?
我很喜欢那个。我大概，就像两天前。不好意思。总之。请不要在我的播客上宣传其他播客。不要去看、去听那个播客。我们没有。叫什么来着？
The podcast name is goes about same. Why would you? Erin. She wanted to know. I think you could tell a later. That was a true question. I thought it was a genuine question. Bop-bar, off the podcast.
播客名字叫goes about same。你为什么要这样？艾琳。她想知道。我觉得你等下可以说。那是个真诚的问题。我觉得是个真诚的问题。Bop-bar，退出播客。
Failed. Banished. Canceled. Go far outside and. Go sit outside and eat those spots. Then, farmed. And we just...
失败。放逐。取消。去外面。去外面坐着吃那些痘痘。然后，种地。然后我们...
Everyone's giving me shit for a spot outside. We just ate sausages, so you know it's not smelling very good. This episode is more for us, and it's more for us being able to look back in the future in five years' time. Back of this cabin. And back into this cabin with the fucking hot fireplace. When you have a million subscribers.
当我拥有百万订阅者时。而且还有……所以那个壁炉，那只鸡，那只虐待母鸡并到处放屁的大公鸡。E.J.放屁了。还有E.J.放屁了，但我们可以深情地回想起来。所以，哦，天哪。所以，我想这真是一个很好的过渡。
When I have a million subscribers. And also there's... So the fireplace, the cock, the big old roost up, that abuses the hens and makes farts. E.J. Farts. And E.J. Farts, but we can think back on it fondly. So, oh, my God. So, I guess that's a really good segue.
好了。回到正轨。回到正轨。那么，五年后。太棒了。有点转折。不，我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。不，我只是以为在我们进入关于五年后的那个问题之前，我们还会有一个问题。
All right. Back on track. Back on track. So, five years time. Love it. It's a bit of a chop. No, I can love this. I love this. No, I just thought we were going to have a question before we got to the five years' part of question.
好吧，那你觉得两年后你会怎么样？不，那个更糟。对，五年。我们还是坚守那个问题。所以五年后。你觉得五年后我们会去哪里？我们正在度过一个美妙的周末。你觉得五年后我们还会做这件事吗？
Okay, well, what do you think you're going to be in two years' time? No, that's worse. Yeah, five years. We'll stick to the question. So five years' time. Where do you think we're going to be in five years time? We're having an amazing weekend. Do you think we're going to be doing this in five years?
我们会去哪儿？单独还是作为团队？单独。哦，好吧，我在大学时有一个整整十年的计划。我确切地知道自己将在哪里。在32岁左右，然后我有一个五年计划。我觉得这依然是我的目标。真的吗？
Where are we going to be? Individually or as a group? Individually. Oh, okay, so I had like a whole 10-year plan at uni. I knew exactly where I was going to be. at like 32 and then I had a five year plan. I think it's still the go. Really?
我很喜欢那样。显然它真的改变了，因为我是2020年毕业的，我本来想在大学毕业后去旅行一年。但显然因为新冠我没去成。所以我最后直接一头扎进职业生涯中，你知道吗？所以我基本上有了这样一个想法：花两年半的时间专门工作、赚钱。然后我要抛下一切，搬到爱尔兰去，然后当一名酒保。
I love to do that. Obviously it really changed because I graduated in 2020 and I wanted to like travel for a year after uni. But like obviously I didn't because of COVID. So I've ended up jumping into my career, you know? So I've kind of got this idea of doing two and a half years of just like working, earning money. And then I'm going to drop everything and move to Ireland and then become a bartender.
就像我今天跟你们说的，我只想去旅行，学一门语言。然后有这样一个……爱尔兰语。对。我只想做那个两 and a half years。盖尔语。盖尔语。
And like I was telling you guys today, and I just want to travel, learn a language. And there's like this like... Irish. Yeah. And I just want to do that for like two and a half years. Gaelic. Gaelic.
抱歉。爱尔兰语是一种语言？不，但他们说的是盖尔语，我想。爱尔兰的语言是盖尔语。所以你要学盖尔语？哦，我没料到会有这个。法语。其实挺难的。
Sorry. Irish is a language? No, but they say Gaelic, I think. The language is Gaelic in Ireland. So you're going to learn Gaelic? Oh, I didn't anticipate anything about that. French. It's quite hard actually.
但我当时也在想，我可能要去西班牙教大约三个月的英语什么的。那是个好主意。我只是想做点什么，你知道的？盖尔语。是盖尔语。那是苏格兰的吧。我以为那是威尔士语。威尔士语又不一样了。
But I was also thinking I'm maybe going to like Spain and teaching like English for like three months or something. That's a good idea. I just want to do something, you know? Gaelic. It's Gaelic. That's not Scotland. I thought that was Welsh. Welsh is different again.
我觉得有苏格兰盖尔语和爱尔兰盖尔语。好吧，也许你只是学爱尔兰人母语的那种语言。对。那可能是盖尔语，也可能是威尔士语。我们不知道。对。绝对不是威尔士语。可能是爱尔兰语。
I think there's Scottish Gaelic and Irish Gaelic. Well, maybe you just learned the language that is native to the Irish people. Yeah. And it could be Gaelic and it could be Welsh. We don't know. Yeah. It's definitely not Welsh. It could be Irish.
对。E.J.的五年计划听起来非常美好。我们不要贬低它。哇，我没想到会这样。我不知道。好吧，我不是那个意思。不，我很喜欢思考我的工作、赚钱以及思考我想去哪里。但我也觉得，我身上有一种元素因为新冠而没有得到满足。
Yeah. EJ's five your plan sounds very beautiful. Let's not undermine it. Whoa, I didn't anticipate that. I don't know. Well, I didn't mean that. No, I'm like very like, I've loved thinking about my job and getting money and thinking about where I want to go. But I'm also like, I feel like there's an element to me that hasn't been fulfilled because of COVID.
所以我非常满足于把我的职业生涯和我的生活分开。尤其是当我年轻、处在二十多岁的时候，我要为自己创造那种未来。所以，真的，我对现在的工作很满意。我对这一切都很满意。但是，嗯，我已经准备好说一声“再见”，然后去海外结识更多的人，你知道的，对，对，你知道，那是……你觉得那会发生在什么时候？在接下来的两年里。对，100%。我目标是在明年的这个时候搬到海外去。真的吗？我的意思是，这可能不会发生。
And so I'm very content with just separating my professional career and my life. And especially when I'm young and in my 20s, I'm going to like create that future for me. So like I really, I'm happy where I am in my job. I'm happy with all that. But like, I'm ready to kind of just say, goodbye and then go overseas meet more people you know yeah yeah you know that's like and what when do you think that's going to happen in the next two years yeah 100% I'm like aiming for like September next year to be like moved overseas what yeah I mean it might not happen
所以，就像，但我正在努力将它具象化。我希望，我会想……不过我最近有很多账单，所以我的积蓄在减少。对，你总能存钱的。你总能存钱的。对，完全是这样。这是一种非常浪漫的看法，但我一直都很乐观。我非常……是的，我已经准备好去做了。你知道的，他们说的是2023年，对吧？对，就在新冠刚过的时候。事实上，他们说2023年是国际旅行重新恢复的时候。更像是正常化，带引号的正常化。就像我们仍然在进行国际旅行，但感觉还是有点……好吧，你们要去巴厘岛，还有你们要去欧洲，我要去欧洲。对，我想我要去拉斯维加斯，我要去……
yeah so like but like manifesting it I hope I would like I've had a lot of bills recently though so my savings are going yeah you can always save you can always save yeah exactly it's a very romantic view but I've always I'm very optimistic I'm very like yeah I'm ready to do it you know they said 2023 didn't they yeah right at the side of COVID exactly actually they said they said 2023 was the time international like kind of travel would happen again it's more like normal yeah in quotation marks normalised like we're still internationally traveling but it's like still a bit well you guys are going to Bali what and you're going to Europe I'm going to Europe yeah I think I'm going to be Vegas going
梅格要去……和我们一起去巴厘岛。我们在试图说服她。梅格要去汤斯维尔（Townsville）。那几乎是……因尼斯韦尔（Innisfail）。因尼斯韦尔。几乎就是国际旅行了。
Meg's going to... To Bali with us. We're trying to convince her. Meg's going to Townsville. That's pretty much... Innesvale. Innesvale. Pretty much international.
对。从斯威夫特克里克出发。是的。开车去因尼斯韦尔花的时间和去找……我本来想说这可能和出国旅行差不多。很可能。可能更贵。飞去因尼斯韦尔可能还要更贵。
Yeah. From Swift's Creek. Yes. It takes just as much time to drive to Inesvale as it does to find... I was going to say it's probably similar to travel. Probably. Probably more expensive. Probably more expensive to even fly to Inisfil.
天哪。现在，要多少钱？便宜多了。对。对。哇。500美元。500美元。
Geez. Now, how much? Much cheaper. Yeah. Yeah. Wow. $500. $500.
更贵了。但这就像杰玛开车12个小时去昆士兰，然后去布里斯班的机票只要80美元。不，但是去布里斯班的机票……从悉尼出发。从悉尼出发去布里斯班的机票真的很便宜。从堪培拉出发就很贵。但重要的是旅程，而不是目的地。而且我度过了一个伟大的……
It's more. But this is like Gemma drove like 12 hours to Queensland and then the flights to Brisbane was like $80. No, but the flights to Brisbane are... From Sydney. From Sydney, the flights to Brisbane are really cheap. From camera, they're really expensive. But it's the journey, it's not the destination. And I had a great...
好吧，我的旅程包括我遭遇了一起肇事逃逸。所以，记住，当有人把我的车窗、车镜从车上撞飞，而我不得不支付300美元时。我觉得这是一个绝对神奇的梦想，E.J.，谢谢你。在马利亚看着你，用盖尔语对你说话。在我的脑海里，在我的脑海里，这非常……不是要把梦想强加在你们身上，但在我的脑海里，
Well, okay, my journey involved me getting a hit and run. So, remember, when someone knocked my window off my mirror off my car and I have to pay $300. I think that's an absolutely magical dream, E, James. Thank you. at you, Malia and speak to you in Gaelic. In my head, in my head, this is very, like, not to put dreams onto you guys, but in my head,
杰玛将在英国攻读硕士学位。她会去，梅格将去欧洲进行一次旅行，然后艾琳将住在，就像，和你一起。对，准确地说，我是一个，抱歉，我们将要，我们将要，
Gemma's going to be in the UK doing her masters. She's going to be, Meg's going to be doing a tour around Europe, and then Erin's going to be living in, like, with you. Yeah, exactly. I'm a, sorry, we're going to be, we're going to be,
我们将要，我们将一起生活。我们将成为爱尔兰一家酒吧楼上的室友。哦，哦，你们就像你们的男朋友一样。杰克和乔什（Jack and Josh）？他们应该上来吗？我是说，如果他们想上来的话。我想，杰克肯定会。我在说话。
we're going to be, we will be living together. We will be roommates above a bar in Ireland. Oh, oh, you just like your boyfriend. Jack and Josh? Should they come up? I mean, if they want to come to come up. I'd like, Jack definitely would. I'm speaking.
嗯，我觉得乔什会。乔什会。我是说，我希望如此。如果你正在听这个，你可能没在听，但你们俩将成为最好的朋友。我们在脑海里规划着呢。这是五年计划的一部分吗？这是公开的。
Well, I think Josh would. Josh would. I mean, I hope so. If you're listening to this, you're probably not, but you guys are going to become best friends. We're planning it in our heads. Is that part of the five-year plan? This is public.
这是公开的。这是公开的。这是五年计划的一部分。对。我们要去住一个，什么，我们想要一个三居室的房子吗？三居室。对，三居室。对，因为那样我们要养一个小……
This is public. This is public. This is part of the five-year plan. Yeah. We are going to go and live in a, what, do we want, like a three-bedroom house? Three-bedroom. Yeah, three-bedroom. Yeah, because then we're going to get a little.
梅格也可以来。我们可以腾出一张床。梅根和杰夫可以来拜访我们，然后我们可以去爱尔兰做我们各自的零工。没错。我愿意住在爱尔兰。我很想住在爱尔兰。好吧，所以基本上艾琳顺势跳上了这列顺风车。E.J.的梦想。
And May can come. We can show a bed. Megan Jeff can come visit us and then we can like go and do whatever jobies we do in Ireland. Exactly. I'd live in Ireland. I'd love to live in Ireland. Okay, so basically Aaron has jumped on the band right. E.J.'s dream.
不，但这真是一个伟大的梦想。而且我们一起生活得很好。我都快热死了。我很抱歉。非常暖和。E.J.和我以前一起住过，为了让听众知道。所以我们知道彼此的生活习惯是什么样的。我们是非常合得来的室友。
No, but it's a great dream. And we do great living together. I'm sweating my tits off. I'm sorry. It's very warm. E.J. and I have previously lived together just to the listener knows. So we know what each other's living style is like. We're very compatible housemates.
我会说，E.J.，你觉得怎么样？她不喜欢我早上的奶昔。哦，天哪，其实是的，那是真的。我早上不做奶昔，因为我担心会吵醒男孩们。因为我去找我的室友。梅刚才找到了一片薯片。把它拿开。
I would say E.J. How do you feel? She doesn't like my smoothies in the morning Oh god, actually yeah, that's true I don't do smoothies in the morning because I'm worried I'm going to wake up the boys Because I go to my housemates I make just found a chip Let's move that away
但我大概11点上床睡觉，然后6点或7点醒来。E.J.以前就是这样的。然后她会在早上6点把奶昔搅拌机打开。我会感到非常非常沮丧。而且你们都知道我本来就不是个早起的人。哦，天哪。今天早上我们全
But I go to bed at like 11 And then wake up at like 6 or 7 That's what EJ used to do And then she used to put the smoothie blender on at 6am And I would be very, very upset And you all know I'm already not a morning person Oh my God This morning we all
都去了海滩，而艾琳留在床上。抱歉。然后她就像，你们整个早上都在说话。而且她是一个人对付我们三个。她还塞着耳塞。我还是能听到你们说话。这太离谱了。听起来像个新问题。
went to the beach and Aaron stayed in bed. Sorry. And then she was like, you guys were talking all more. And she had three against one as well. And she had ear plugs in. I can still hear you. It was ridiculous. It sounds like a new problem.
其实确实是。这曾是个大问题。完全公平地说。你们大家都在愉快地聊天。我们在拥抱。哦。而你从不给我们拥抱。那是因为我得了流感。
It does actually. It was a big problem. To be completely fair. You guys were all having a lovely chart. We were having cuddles. Oh. And you never give us cuddles. That's because I've got the flow.
我不在乎。甲型流感，宝贝。那么梅格，你的终极五年计划是什么？哦。艾琳已经直接跳上了E.J.的梦想的顺风车。
I don't care. Influenza A, babe. So Meg, what is your final? year plan. Oh. Erin has already just jumps on the bandwagon of EJ's.
你再也拿不到别的安全保障了。我的梦想降格为搭上E.J.梦想的顺风车，除此之外别无他求。所以梅格，你的五年计划是什么？听着，说实话，我真的不知道。
You don't get any more safe. My dreams are reduced to jumping on the bandwagon of EJ's dreams and nothing else. So Meg, what's your five-year plan? Look, to be honest, I don't really know
你再也得不到任何安全感了。我的梦想简化成了盲目跟风EJ的梦想，别无其他。所以，梅格，你的五年计划是什么？听着，说实话，我真的不知道
what I'm doing at the moment. You know, I don't have a certain thing I want to do. But I'm saying that, travel is definitely something I've missed out on too, like EJ said. So definitely going overseas,
我目前在做的事。你知道的，我没有一件特别想做的事。但我得说，正如EJ所说，旅行绝对是我错过的一项。所以肯定会去海外，
living over there or travelling both for a bit. Definitely Asia. Asia. Like Central Asia. Yeah. That's why you should come to Bali. Yes. Which is not one of the Central Asia?
去那边住一段时间或者去旅游。绝对是亚洲。亚洲。比如中亚。对。这就是为什么你应该来巴厘岛。是的。哪个不属于中亚？
No. No. But it's travel. Maybe, yes. And then... What about your three-month plan? Because you've got some big plans. Oh, yes.
不。不是。但这是旅行。也许吧，是的。然后……你的三个月计划怎么样？因为你有一些大计划。哦，是的。
I am finishing my job in two weeks in Swiss Creek. And I'm going up to Queensland to do some other seasonal work. which is yet to be decided. TBA. TBA and what I'm doing, but it'll probably be outdoor work. Yeah. A bit of group-picking.
两周后我将结束在斯威士溪（Swiss Creek）的工作。我要去昆士兰做点别的季节性工作，具体做什么还没定。待定。待定，不过可能是在户外工作。对。摘摘水果之类的。
Yeah, something like that. Yeah, so that's exciting and be of a change. That's where me and Erin are from. Good news. Boo-ya, baby. I will visit your hometown. You will visit my hometown. Don't visit Brisbane.
对，大概那种。对，所以这很令人兴奋，也会是一种改变。我和埃琳（Erin）就是那里的人。好消息。太棒了，宝贝。我会去参观你的家乡。你会去参观我的家乡。别去布里斯班。
Brisbane's not worth going to. Don't say that one was his dunnings from there. I was going to visit. Again, truly not really. worth. People like visiting Brisbane as tourists. I'm sorry, my hometown is fucking beautiful. Yeah. You can visit it.
布里斯班不值得去。别那么说，他的家人就住那儿。我本来打算去参观的。讲真，真的不怎么值得。人们喜欢去布里斯班当游客。对不起，我的家乡美极了。对。你可以去参观。
I've never been to Brisbane. Corrumban is beautiful. Don't go to Brisbane. Go to Corrumban. I will. I will. Small town, baby. Anyhow. But in five years' time, where are you living, Meg?
我从未去过布里斯班。库伦甘（Corrumban）很美。别去布里斯班。去库伦甘。我会的。我会的。小镇，宝贝。不管怎样。但在五年后，你住在哪里，梅格？
Probably overseas. I might be close to Ireland. No, but definitely overseas. Probably I want to go to Canada next. year maybe yeah oh that would be fun that incredible overseas or doing something maybe outdoorsy or with you know hands-on I'm not sure yeah you do um seasonal firefighting
可能在海外。我可能会离爱尔兰近一点。不，但绝对在海外。可能我明年想去加拿大，也许吧，哦，那会很有趣，那太不可思议了，在海外或者做一些户外的事情，或者你知道的，亲自动手，我不太确定，对，你做……季节性消防工作
in Canada potentially but next year oh not seasonal firefighting well you can do seasonal firefighting but it's like it's a really interesting wait just canadian Canada do they pay you um does Canada pay you to plant trees yeah but it's actually like one of the most work like it's it's really interesting job because it pays really well and you like it's outdoors and you kind of go and living these like little like camps for like months of a time but it's actually really really really hard because you get paid per tree that's like australia's how much you get per tree like 20 cents yeah so you got to plant a lot of trees yeah but once you get going you get like the body gets used to it my head first i'm
在加拿大，潜在的，但是明年，哦，不是季节性消防，好吧，你可以做季节性消防，但它就像是一个非常有趣的，等等，加拿大，他们付钱吗，呃，加拿大付钱让你种树吗？对，但它实际上是工作中最……就像这是一个非常有趣的工作，因为它报酬很高，而且你就像是在户外，你得去这些小营地里生活几个月，但实际上真的真的真的很难，因为你是按树的数量拿报酬的，就像澳大利亚一样，一棵树多少钱，比如20美分，所以你得种很多树，对，但一旦你上手了，身体就习惯了，我一开始...
my head for somebody like pictureing a giant plant yeah i can plan a tree in like oh no you should watch these like i went through a phase when i was living in counter on exchange where I was like, I'm going to become a tree planter, because I met this person who was like, yeah, I was a tree planter and I'm going back. I was like, oh, that's so interesting. And, um, but I watch these YouTube blogs and, like, people get like, like, your body, like, does not recover. Like, the shorter you are, the better because you're closer to the ground. Yeah, yeah. That's very true.
我一开始脑子里想象的是种一棵巨型的植物，对，我可以在大概……哦，不，你应该看看这些，当我以交换生身份住在加拿大时，我经历过一个阶段，当时我想，我要成为一名植树工，因为我遇到了一个人，他就像是，对，我曾经是一名植树工，而且我要回去了。我就想，哦，这太有趣了，而且，呃，但是我看了这些YouTube博客，就像是，人们的身体，根本无法恢复。个子越矮越好，因为你离地面更近。对，对。这非常对。
What if you're a midget? It's perfect for you because you don't have to bend down. You also have to, okay, think about this. You've got to carry, like, all the stuff you need for tree planting so that you've got, like, and then, like, you need water. And then, like, you need water. And then they just dump you in the middle of a paddard. all day and then you just got like dig holes and plant trees all day and you did nothing else and do they go around and count the trees that you pile no they count how many
如果你是个侏儒呢？这简直完美，因为你不用弯腰。你还得，好吧，想想这个。你得背着所有植树需要的东西，所以你得有……然后，你需要水。然后，你需要水。然后他们把你扔在一片草地的中央，一整天，然后你一整天都得挖坑种树，什么都不做，他们会四处走动数你种的树吗？不，他们数你背包里有多少
trees are in your backpack yeah yeah but then like I saw these things of people who'd like big digging trees and they'd hit like a hornet's nest and then they get like bitten on their face by like all these like bees that's like a fucking hungry game and then there's like bears yeah this sounds terrible yeah but they can pay really well because like you work for like three months and you own like quite a significant amount money and you make friends and quite a lot of young people do it and you get eaten by a bear well I didn't say a vlog of somebody getting eaten by bear but it's certainly a hazard Aaron so that's your five-year goal is it no absolutely to be eaten by a bear in Canada planning
树苗。对，对。但后来我看到有人说，他们挖树时碰到了胡蜂窝，然后脸就被所有这些蜜蜂叮了，这就像是该死的饥饿游戏，然后还有熊，对，这听起来太糟糕了，对，但他们报酬很高，因为你干三个月就能赚到相当大的一笔钱，还能交到朋友，很多年轻人都会这么做，然后你被熊吃掉，好吧，我没看到有人被熊吃掉的视频，但它肯定是个隐患，埃琳，所以你的五年目标就是这个吗，在加拿大种松树时被熊吃掉
pine trees yes well and it's an interesting thing because I think no just quickly I think they plant the trees for forestry so they plant them so they grow and then they're cutting down again so it's not even like fun tree regeneration oh yeah like it's like native and stuff yeah that's a lot in Australia too. So it's commercial. It's commercial. Oh, that sounds fucked. Why do I do that?
对，好吧，这是一件很有趣的事，因为我认为，不，等一下，我想他们种树是为了林业，所以他们种植它们让其生长，然后再次砍掉，所以甚至都不是为了有趣的树木再生，哦，对，就像本地树种之类的，对，澳大利亚也有很多。所以这是商业化的。这是商业化的。哦，这听起来太糟了。我为什么要做那个？
And you think that a machine can do it in this day and age? Maybe so. It's a bit rough. Yeah, and I think so kind of remote like that's actually. You're like helicopter drops. But think about this,
你觉得现在这个时代机器能干这个吗？也许吧。有点粗糙。对，而且我觉得这种偏远地区其实……就像直升机空投一样。但想想这个，
because the tree, it would plant it in the front and then it would probably run it over. Just think about, so the tree, like, think about a machine and think about like, no. How do you think they plant crops? I don't know. With seeds.
因为这棵树，它会在前面种下它，然后它可能会从它上面碾过去。只要想想，所以这棵树，比如，想想一台机器，然后想想……不。你觉得他们是怎么种庄稼的？我不知道。用种子。
It's seeds. In the back. back. Oh, and then they go in the front and I was like, why would you do that? Because then you're going to run over the trees. I do not work with my hands. It's very obvious. I do not have a
是种子。在后面。后面。哦，然后它们走到前面，我当时就想，你为什么要做那个？因为那样你会把树给碾过去的。我不从事体力劳动。这很明显。我没有
working woman's job. I work in an office. I like that. Working woman's job. Yeah. I'm just a little office bitch. A little corporate bitch. Yeah. So your five-year plan is involving travel. Well, theoretically, but I
工薪阶层的职业。我在办公室工作。我喜欢这个。工薪阶层的职业。对。我只是个小办公室碧池。一个小公司碧池。对。所以你的五年计划涉及旅行。嗯，理论上是，但我
like to pry myself on the fact that I don't have five-year plan. No, I was literally about to say this. Like, I was like, I was like, I talk a lot about having plans, but like, especially with what COVID's taught me, it's like good to not have a plan. It's good to, like, have this, like, optimism, you know? Yeah. Yeah. I think I'm the same, although I'm going to be honest, I have a pretty, pretty intense five-year plan. Yeah. I think five-year, like, I'm somebody in general, just quickly. Yeah. Because I feel quite strongly about this topic. Great. That's what we want on the podcast. I'm somebody who, like, I never made goals. I'm somebody who, like, I never made goals ever like even when I was at school and they're like you got to make a goal I was like
喜欢以此为傲，事实上我没有五年计划。不，我刚想这么说。就像，我当时想，我当时想，我经常谈论制定计划，但特别是经历了新冠疫情教会我的事，最好还是顺其自然。最好有这种乐观精神，你知道吗？对。对。我想我也一样，虽然说实话，我有一个相当、相当密集的五年计划。对。我觉得五年，就像，我总体上是一个人，等一下。对。因为我对这个话题感触很深。太棒了。这正是我们在播客中想要的。我是一个这样的人，我从不制定目标。我是一个从来不制定目标的人，甚至当我在学校的时候，他们说你得定个目标，我就想
I don't want to make a goal because it's just going to lead to disappointment and a fear of failure that's less great so because of fear of failure I never wanted to do you did you ever have like sorry to go off try but did you ever like academic like validation like did you ever like in high school like get an assignment and you're like I want top grade uh yeah of course is that not similar that's a goal that's a goal but like I would never make a goal by myself like I would never do a goal myself. I'd just be like, oh, I'm going to get this assignment and I'm going to do well because I do well. Oh, you, okay. The assignment was already set. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. So it's like somebody set to me. A society told you that life goals are more abstract. Life goals are very
我不想定目标，因为那只会导致失望和对失败的恐惧，那不太好。所以因为害怕失败，我从来不想做……你有没有过——抱歉打断一下，特雷——你有没有过那种学术上的认可，比如你在高中时拿到一份作业，然后你想得最高分？呃，当然。那不类似吗？那是一个目标，那是一个目标。但如果是我自己，我绝不会给自己定目标，我绝对不会自己去定目标。我只会觉得，哦，我要拿到这个作业，然后我要把它做好，因为我能做好。哦，你，好吧。作业已经布置好了。对，对，对，对。所以这就好像是别人给我的。社会告诉你人生目标更抽象。人生目标非常
abstract. They're not set for you. Because there's multiple paths as well. Like a school assignment, you don't have multiple paths. Yeah. But life, you have many multiple paths. It's what you can do and what you can pick and there's like an intense amount of variables and it's very scary. And so I, I... This is true. You just had three glasses of wine. She's feeling as... Life is beautiful.
抽象。它们不是为你设定好的。因为也有多条道路。就像学校作业，你没有多条道路。对。但生活，你有很多多条道路。这是你能做的和你能选择的，有大量的变量，这非常可怕。所以，我……这是真的。你刚刚喝了三杯酒。她感觉……生活真美好。
So gorgeous. But yeah, so I don't make goals because I don't like goals and they make me stressed. Fair enough. Yeah, I think there can be a healthy balance in it. This is very true. Anyway, what's your one? You've got... I'm enjoying this.
太美了。不过，对，所以我绝不立目标，因为我不喜欢目标，它们会让我感到压力。也对。对，我觉得这其中可以有一种健康的平衡。这非常真实。不管怎样，你的目标是什么？你已经有……我很享受这个。
Well, yeah, no. Because you've got the opposite of what Aaron is. Oh, yeah, absolutely. But I just think it's quite restrictive as well because I think if you make a goal... But it's not restrictive. It's just like... Because the goals are like... No, no, no, but I mean that like my goals are just goals
嗯，对，没有。因为你拥有的跟亚伦完全相反。哦，对，绝对是。但我只是觉得这也相当束缚，因为我觉得如果你立了一个目标……但它并不束缚。它只是像……因为目标就像是……不，不，不，我的意思是，我的目标只是目标
and my life is created around them. Yeah, it's good to have a direction, I guess. Well, it's just like, I want to be... But, hey, it's not like, my goals are a lot more. I think my goals are a lot more. They're not like, I need to be living in a house with my partner and have three children and I would like a dog and its name would be penny. Like, it's more like, I know that in two years I want to be doing my master's in a living.
而我的生活是围绕着它们构建的。对，有个方向挺好的，我猜。嗯，这就像，我想成为……但是，嘿，它不像，我的目标要多得多。我觉得我的目标要多得多。它们不像，我需要和伴侣住在一个房子里，生三个孩子，我想要一只狗，名字叫佩妮。相反，它更像是，我知道两年后我想在国外读硕士并生活。
Because I think a lot of people make those goals that you were talking about in the first instance. So it's like, I need a house and pets and a child. And I think that's why a lot of people, like, for example, when they can't have kids, they get really disappointed because their whole life has been about this one goal and fulfilling this one role. Yeah. Whereas mine is like, also it's too. Which we could go on about for a mom's time. We can probably jump into that in a later day.
因为我觉得很多人在一开始就设定了你刚才说的那种目标。所以就像是，我需要一套房子、宠物和一个孩子。我想这就是为什么很多人，比如当他们不能生孩子时，会感到非常失望，因为他们整个人生都围绕着这个单一的目标和履行这个单一的角色展开。对。而我的则是，而且这也太……我们可以聊上好一阵子。我们或许可以改天再深入探讨。
Yeah. Whereas my goal is like, I know that in two years I want to be in London, studying my master's. Yeah. That's not a constrictive goal. Totally, totally. Yeah, that's like I want to be, I know I want to be overseas next year, but I, like, I did say September. But, like, I was, I know in the foreseeable future, I would love to be overseas, wherever that is, you know? Yeah.
对。而我的目标是，我知道两年后我想在伦敦攻读硕士。对。那不是一个具束缚性的目标。完全，完全。对，这就好像我想，我知道我明年想去海外，但我，就像，我确实说过九月。但是，就像，我，我知道在可预见的未来，我很想去海外，无论那是哪里，你知道吗？对。
It's a very interesting thing. Yeah. See, I think because I've had so many things happen in life that have happened purely by chance. And I think, as well, propelled somewhat by COVID, where I've made. a big life plan I was like so ready to do all these things after exchange and go travelling and then none of that could happen I was like well that's the last time I ever make a goal because that didn't happen and it was so disappointing and very upsetting and like a huge waste of like energy even getting myself to that point
这是一件非常有趣的事情。对。你看，我觉得是因为我在生活中经历过太多完全出于偶然的事情。而且我也觉得，在某种程度上被新冠疫情所推动，当时我制定了一个宏大的生活计划，我简直准备好在交换生结束后做所有这些事情去旅行，然后这一切都无法实现，我就想，好吧，这是我最后一次立目标，因为那根本没有发生，这太令人失望、太难过了，而且就像是在精力上巨大的浪费，甚至连把自己推到那个地步也是
only to have the rug pulled from underneath me I think it's like I think it's good to have that like realistic like perspective of it but I also I can't see where jam is coming from I really that can be such a happy balance and I think that a lot of it has to do with like as well my general life mindset is a very negative one. Yes, we've talked about this before. We've talked about this before. But also, Aaron, I don't have a partner. Yeah.
结果却美梦破碎。我觉得就像，我觉得对它保持那种现实的视角是好的，但我同样，我也能理解詹姆的想法，真的，这可以有一种非常快乐的平衡，而且我觉得这很大程度上也与我的整体生活心态非常消极有关。是的，我们以前讨论过这个。我们以前讨论过这个。但还有，亚伦，我没有伴侣。对。
I don't have anything tying me anywhere. Yeah. But like I have a partner and I, and he is extremely aware of like my boundaries in the sense where I have like gone into that and it's been like, I want to be overseas. I want to be doing this and these are things I want to achieve in my life. Do you think long distance helps with that? I think so.
我没有任何把我拴在任何地方的东西。对。但比如我有一个伴侣，而且他非常清楚我的界限，在这个意义上，我曾深入谈过这个，并且说过：我想去海外。我想做这个，这些是我在生活中想要实现的成就。你觉得异地恋对这有帮助吗？我觉得有。
I think he's really been open-minded to my perspective. because I also think I don't want him to be restricted. His goal setting, I don't want his life to just revolve around me. So in my head, I'm like, I want to be overseas with consideration that maybe he wants to join me. But if he doesn't want me, doesn't want to, like, we can work through that. You know what I mean? I do. Honestly, it's been interesting because I've been having, like, a real, like, I love, the thing is, I haven't really met Meg's partner.
我觉得他真的对我的观点持开放态度。因为我也觉得我不想束缚他。他的目标设定，我不想他的生活仅仅围绕着我转。所以在我的脑海里，我想的是，我想去海外，同时考虑到他可能想加入我。但如果他不想，不想的话，我们可以一起克服。你知道我的意思吗？我懂。说实话，这很有趣，因为我一直在经历一种真实的，像我喜欢，问题是，我其实没怎么见过梅格的伴侣。
But I've met, but wait, wait, wait, wait. I've met Jack, obviously. I've met Aaron's partner. I know Aaron and EJ's partners quite well, I would say. And I feel like, and all of my friends at the moment have boyfriends and partners. But that's one thing. And I've been feeling like kind of sad about it because like obviously I went through a breakup at the start of the year. It like completely destroyed me.
但我见过，但是等等，等等，等等。我当然见过杰克。我见过亚伦的伴侣。我想我对亚伦和E.J.的伴侣都很熟悉。而且我觉得，我现在的所用朋友都有男朋友和伴侣。但这只是一回事。我为此感到有点难过，因为很明显我在年初经历了一次分手。这彻底摧毁了我。
We've talked about it a lot. But moving onwards. Moving onwards. Fuck him. But the thing is it's like I have been like kind of in a weird headspace about it recently. And then I'm like, actually, there are some pretty. amazing upsides to it. For example, if tomorrow I decided, oh, like, I want to move to London. Yeah. You can do that. I could literally do it. Yeah. And also my work is so great that I could do it
我们已经讨论过很多次了。但生活还要继续。生活还要继续。去他的吧。但问题是，我最近对这件事的心态有点诡异。然后我想，其实，这里面也有一些相当惊人的积极面。比如，如果明天我决定，哦，像，我想搬去伦敦。对。你可以做到。我完全可以做到。对。而且我的工作也那么棒，我甚至可以把工作也带过去
as well. Like, it's a beautiful thing. I had a really interesting conversation with Jack the other day. I could also move to Toronto. Sorry, go. Sorry. Oh, Jesus. Choice of. I'm not going to move to fucking Toronto. Yeah. You know how my seasonal depression be. Um, I had a really interesting conversation with Jack the other day about this as a concept. because like when you're with somebody I was like at the end of the day you've got to prioritise yourself number one baby
这真是件美妙的事。我前几天和杰克进行了一次非常有趣的谈话。我也可能搬去多伦多。抱歉，请继续。抱歉。哦，天哪。这选择。我才不会搬去他妈的多伦多。对。你知道我的季节性抑郁是怎么回事的。嗯，我前几天和杰克关于这个概念进行了一次非常有趣的谈话。因为就像当你和某人在一起时，我当时就觉得，归根结底你必须把自己放在第一位，宝贝
so whatever you want to do like even if that involves not having me around at the end of the day it's about you and about your life and don't constrain your life yeah to suit the relationship you're in because at the end of the day all you have is yourself Megan and I were talking about this yes we were literally an hour ago
所以无论你想做什么，即使这涉及没有我在身边，归根结底这关乎你自己和你的人生，不要为了迎合你所在的恋爱关系而约束你的人生，因为到头来你拥有的只有自己。我和梅格一直在谈论这个，是的，我们就在一个小时前还聊过
but like I also think makes a good example and says she's still going to Queensland and has a partner people always ask me Are you going with Takama? No, I'm not. Exactly, it's not coming. You're creating my own reality. Yeah.
但我也觉得梅格是个好榜样，她说她还是要独自去昆士兰，并且她有伴侣。人们总是问我：你要和塔卡马一起去吗？不，我没有。没错，他不会来。你在创造我自己的现实。对。
Is that hard? You know? No, I've always planned to go by myself. Yeah. It's my plan. Yeah. Good on you. Because you had a goal.
这很难吗？你知道吗？不，我一直计划自己一个人去。对。这是我的计划。对。真棒。因为你有一个目标。
Yeah. A goal, and it's a goal that is useful. Mm-hmm. But back to this, I think in five years' time, I would like to, A, I'm going to say this, I would like to have not been in a relationship in that period. Yeah. I am pretty set on staying single with a capital S for the next five years. I would like to have a lot of new friends.
对。一个目标，而且是一个有用的目标。嗯。但回到正题，我觉得在五年后，我会希望，A，我要说这个，我希望在那段时间里没有谈恋爱。对。我相当坚决要在接下来的五年里保持单身，大写加粗的单身。我希望有很多新朋友。
Okay. I would like to be doing. No, no, no. I'll just be showing myself out. But I would like, and then I... That's the natural. Yeah, but I would like to have a continue... Like, obviously, you guys aren't people I'm letting go of,
好吧。我希望自己正在做。不，不，不。我还是自己退场吧。但我希望，然后我……那是自然而然的。对，但我希望有一个持续的……很明显，你们不是我想要放手的人，
and I'd like to live somewhere other than Australia. Although I am a big Sydney fan at the moment. You just move there. I'm obsessed with Sydney. E.J. Can't say the same, but... Made to me. I've never liked to live.
而且我想住在澳大利亚以外的地方。虽然我现在是个坚定的悉尼粉丝。你刚搬到那儿。我迷恋悉尼。E.J.可不这么认为，不过……对我来说。我从来都不喜欢住在这里。
So Meg is living in a pretty small country town. Yes, I am. And we went to this bar yesterday. Oh, it was overwhelming. Yeah, what was your... A bar in Milton. Bar in Milton, New South Wales. So not particular most pump in place.
所以梅格住在一个相当小的乡村小镇里。是的，我是。我们昨天去了这家酒吧。哦，真是让人应接不暇。对，你的……米尔顿的一家酒吧。新南威尔士州米尔顿的酒吧。所以绝不是最热闹的地方。
There were... To be fair, it was different. It was a Mexican bar. Well, a Mexican bar. It was a bit of a weird Australasian fusion. Okay, Austro-Mexican. Austro-Mexican. A whole new cuisine.
那里有……平心而论，它很特别。是一家墨西哥酒吧。嗯，一家墨西哥酒吧。那有点像奇怪的澳墨融合风格。好吧，澳墨风。一种全新的菜系。
Austro-Mexican. And there was just so many people there and they kept staring at me but they weren't it's just because you haven't... You haven't been around large amounts people.
奥地利裔墨西哥人。当时那里有好多人，他们一直盯着我看，但他们不是……这只是因为你没……你没见过那么多的人。
You haven't been around people. Yeah, and then I was then we're talking about Sydney and Canberra even and I get very overwhelmed because there's so many people. Imagine, okay imagine Meg in Sydney with us. E.J. You'd be pretty sure us.
你没怎么见过人。对，然后我说到悉尼甚至堪培拉，我会感到非常不知所措，因为人太多了。想象一下，好吧，想象一下梅格和我们一起在悉尼。E.J. 你肯定很确信我们。
Meg oddly though. I remember when we went to Melbourne and weren't you still living you were living in Bombol at that stage and you coped okay in Melbourne But that might be a familiar stage. I think actually you might be right
不过梅格很奇怪。我记得我们去墨尔本的时候，你当时不是还在住吗，你住在邦博拉，你在墨尔本应付得还行，但这可能是一个你熟悉的阶段。其实我觉得你可能说得对
because I was not okay in Melbourne I know, I know, because that was like the city I knew. Yeah, you're pretty familiar with it but yeah, Sydney you're less familiar with? I mean there a couple times. Yes, sweet. Yeah, very, very true. I feel like you have really really struggled.
因为我在墨尔本感觉不太好。我知道，我知道，因为那就像是我熟悉的城市。对，你对它挺熟悉的，但悉尼你就不太熟悉？我是说去过几次。是的，没错。对，非常非常真实。我觉得你真的挣扎得很厉害。
Here's the thing about Sydney though that I've been really interested. I don't know if you feel the same, E.J. I feel so ugly. Oh my God. This is... What a great. Yeah.
不过关于悉尼，我一直很感兴趣的是。E.J. 不知道你是不是也有同感，我觉得自己好丑。哦，天哪。这是……多棒的观点。对。
No, but I feel... No, this is... No, no, I can... I can agree with her. I can agree with her. There is a different... There's a subculture of beauty that has been... It's a different standard.
不，但我觉得……不，这是……不，不，我能……我能同意她的看法。我能同意她的看法。有一种不同的……有一种美的亚文化已经变成了……这是一个不同的标准。
It's a quickly. It's not a subculture of beauty. It's a subculture of people with a lot of disposable income and very rich parents. So what are they... What are they using for? So there's like... Lip fill is beautiful. Bitch. Basically, I want to get lip fillers.
很快。这不是一种美的亚文化。这是一群有很多可支配收入和非常富有父母的人的亚文化。那他们在……他们在用什么？所以就像是……丰唇膏太美了。贱人。基本上，我想去丰唇。
My hair line. So, no, I was talking to, I was talking to my housemates the other day about this. I don't know what it is. I'm going to blame it all on the guy I was seeing at the start of the year for absolutely destroying my self-confidence. Can I get a what-what? What-what? Yeah, thank you. Silence from everybody else. No.
我的发际线。所以，不，我前几天在和室友聊这个。我不知道这是为什么。我要把这一切都怪罪于今年年初我交往的那个家伙，他彻底摧毁了我的自信。能给我来个“哦耶”吗？哦耶！是的，谢谢。其他人一片沉默。不。
I started and then it was too late. Yes. But I don't know what it is, but when I moved to Sydney, I was like, wow. I'm so ugly, but also just like my personal circumstances where I was like, I'm unlovable. And I was like, I should get lip fillers. And then I was get drunk the other night and I was telling my housemates about it. And I was like, what do you? And I was going to book an appointment.
我开始了，然后就太晚了。是的。但我不知道为什么，当我搬到悉尼时，我想，哇。我太丑了，但也只是像我个人的情况，我觉得自己不可爱。然后我想，我应该去丰唇。然后前几天我喝醉了，我在跟室友说这个。我说，你们觉得呢？我当时正打算预约。
And it was like, have you seen, okay. I googled it. I was, also I'm scared of injections. I was going to say, I, if you ever want to scare yourself out of getting lip fillers, watch the Jeffrey Star video where he gets his lip fillers removed because they were like, went bad and like collagulated in his lips and he films everything. Wait what? Okay, so he got these like really bad.
然后就像是，你看过，好吧。我查了谷歌。而且我很害怕打针。我本来想说，我，如果你想打消丰唇的念头，去看看杰弗里·斯塔（Jeffrey Star）的视频，他去把唇部填充物取出来了，因为它们变质了，在嘴唇里凝结了，而且他把整个过程都拍了下来。等等，什么？好吧，所以他弄了这些非常糟糕的……
This is when, okay, I've got to stop from the beginning. Jeffrey Starr, as people know, is very problematic. I want to assure you that I no longer watch Jeffrey Starr. And if you, but if you did, who cares? Well, I don't want to get cancelled. Council, not cancel. That's our phrase on the show. Council, not cancel.
这是当，好吧，我得从头说起。正如大家所知，杰弗里·斯塔有很多争议。我想向大家保证，我不再看杰弗里·斯塔了。如果你，但如果你看了，谁在乎呢？好吧，我可不想被封杀。取消，而不是封杀。这是我们节目的口头禅。取消，而不是封杀。
But Jeffrey Starr is really problematic. But basically he filled his lip filler like removal. So he had like plastic surgery but he got it like done back in the day when they weren't really like a big mainstream thing. And they just did them really, really wrong. And they like put something in it that got like stuck in his lip. So he had like a lump in his lip. Was it plastic? It was like yeah, some kind of plastic.
但杰弗里·斯塔真的很有争议。不过基本上他是去做了唇部填充物取出手术。所以他做过整形手术，但那是很久以前做的，当时这些还不是主流。他们做得很糟糕很糟糕。他们把某种东西放进去了，结果卡在他的嘴唇里。所以他嘴唇上有个硬块。是塑料吗？就像是，对，某种塑料。
And it didn't like dissolve. And then he had to get them like professionally removed. and like he filmed the whole process of getting removed and I was like I just like I can't I cannot think of anything worse I'd still get it you should watch it and I know I watched it like 14 and I got like mentally scarred by it so yeah recommendation if anybody's on the fence go watch that video I don't even know what's cool now what do you think about it I I've I've thought about that we're in Bombala my old housemate we were talking about it quite seriously yeah about getting it but then I I was pretty like for it but then
而且它没有溶解。然后他不得不去专业机构把它们取出来，而且他把整个取出的过程都拍了下来，当时我就想，我只是觉得，我简直想不出比这更糟糕的事了。我还是会去做的，你应该去看看，我知道我14岁的时候看了，心里留下了阴影，所以，如果有人还在犹豫，建议去看那个视频。我甚至不知道现在流行什么，你觉得呢？我，我考虑过这个，我们在邦博拉的时候，我和以前的室友很严肃地讨论过这件事，关于去丰唇，但后来，我其实挺赞成的，但后来……
I didn't realize you have to get them every like two years. So that's, that's a lot of money every two years. But maybe by the time, you know, by the time when 24, we won't care as much. No, no, that's the thing. Well, same. I was like, I want to get them now because I want the,
我没意识到你每隔两年左右就得补一次。所以这，每两年就要花一大笔钱。但也许到那个时候，你知道的，等我们24岁的时候，我们可能就不会那么在意了。不，不，关键就在这。好吧，我也是。我当时想，我现在就想做，因为我想要……
I mean, my early 20s, that's when you look the best, surely. Yeah. I just want to look really hot. I think I get worried that you get used to the look of them and then you get, like, stuck in the addictive loop of spending money on them. Well, that's moving my eyebrows. Yeah.
我是说，我20岁出头的时候，那是你看起来最好的时候，对吧。我只是想看起来非常辣。我想我担心的是你会习惯它们的样子，然后你就会陷入花钱在这上面的上瘾循环中。好吧，这牵动了我的眉毛。对。
So, just quickly, E.J., but I got my eyebrow, because I, I've been on like this whole like weird self-love, self-confidence journey. And I started getting my eyebrows done and like, what is it called? Tinged. Tinted and done and now I'm addicted. Yeah, because you don't get used to how you look. I spend $50 a month on getting my eyelashes and my eyebrows tinted, which I never thought I would be that person.
所以，简单说一下，E.J.，我做过眉毛，因为我，我一直在经历一种奇怪的自爱、自信之旅。我开始修眉毛，还有什么来着？染色。染色和修整，现在我上瘾了。对，因为你不会习惯自己的样子。我每个月花50美元给睫毛和眉毛染色，我从没想过自己会成为那种人。
Yeah. Even nails. That person is really a thing. Yeah. But E.J, what do you think? So I have this like really back and forth relationship about like, like, cosmetic surgery where it was like so similarly with like like jama i had this like experience with an ex where he's he pointed out that i had really thin a thin upper lip oh it's disgusting
对。甚至美甲。那种人确实存在。对。但是 E.J.，你怎么看？我对整形手术有一种非常反复的态度，就像，就像贾玛一样，我曾与前任有过这样的经历，他指出我上唇很薄，哦，这太恶心了。
i yeah and i got really like insecure about it i was quite young i was just turned 18 sort of thing and what was his name zip zip No calling it. Anyway, I was quite horrible. It was zip, though. And I was quite, like, I became very, like, innately aware of it. And it was something like I would, like, take photos and they were like, oh, my God, I don't know, I'm up in the lip. And I would consider, like, getting, like, lip fillers.
我，是的，我对此感到非常没有安全感。我当时很年轻，刚满18岁左右，那家伙叫什么名字？Zip，Zip。算了，不提了。不管怎样，这真的很糟糕。不过确实叫Zip。我变得非常，怎么说呢，内心对此极其敏感，以至于我会去拍照，然后心想：“天哪，我不知道，我的上唇……”我甚至考虑过要去丰唇。
But I'd always see, like, people on television or people in real life, and it just, either they had overdone it or this kind of stuff. But then I started thinking about it, like, if you feel beautiful and you feel content with your decision and confident in your, decision, like, go ahead, but as long as you're aware of, like, the health precautions. Yeah. But then you start to think, sorry to get really met of here, but it's like, you start thinking about, like, the cosmetic culture and you start thinking of plastic, like, surgery culture. Is it done for, right men benefits of women's insecurities? Exactly. And it's like, what is...
但我总是看到电视上的人或者现实生活中的人，要么是他们做得过头了，要么就是诸如此类的情况。但后来我开始思考，如果你觉得自己很美，对自己的决定感到满意并充满自信，那就去做吧，只要你了解相关的健康防范措施。对。但随后你开始思考，抱歉这里有点深入探讨了，就像，你开始思考美容文化，你开始思考塑料，就像整形外科文化。这真的是为了取悦男性的利益还是满足女性的不安全感？完全正确。这就好比……
Where does the money go? Exactly. And you think, like, what is beauty? It's, like, especially in Western culture, it is like post-colonial beauty of like blue eyes blonde hair it's like yeah you know what I mean that's yeah so many cultures are like it's people like aren't gonna remember you like at your funeral for like your lit tillers they're gonna remember you feel like how kind you wear yeah but I also it's a very interesting thing for me so I'm interested in getting so I think the lip filler thing and the cheek filler thing because that's another thing I'm concerned yeah I'm For yourself?
钱都去哪儿了？完全正确。你会想，什么是美？这就好像，尤其是在西方文化中，它是后殖民时期的美，比如蓝眼睛金头发，就像是，是的，你知道我的意思，那就是，是的，很多文化都觉得，人们不会在你的葬礼上因为你的丰唇而记住你，他们会记住你的善良，对。但对我来说这也是一件非常有趣的事，所以我有兴趣去做，所以我认为丰唇和脸颊填充也是我关心的另一件事，对，我……为了你自己？
But you guys, I think you guys all know, like, the last three months have been hard because I just felt so low. Because this person, like, completely, like, just like, are you doing it for, like, like, I'm not doing it to, like, impress them. I'm not doing it to feel more attractive. Yeah. The only reason I'm doing it is because I'm like, if I had this done, I would actually feel confident enough. Yeah. To be myself. Well, yeah.
但你们大家，我想你们都知道，过去三个月很难熬，因为我情绪真的很低落。因为这个人，就像，完全，就像，你这么做是为了，就像，我这么做不是为了给他们留下深刻印象。我这么做不是为了让自己更有吸引力。对。我这么做的唯一原因是因为我觉得，如果我做了这个，我其实会有足够的自信。对。做回自己。好吧，对。
Because I feel like my external would match my internal. Yeah. But I don't know. That's really interesting though because sometimes I think that that's a bit like the whole concept of like if I buy this dress I will finally be satisfied and never want a black dress that is short and I can wear out again. It's like this culture of wanting. There's a culture of wanting. There's a really, um, Ruby Sparks has a really good book about this. Um, I can't remember what the book's called.
因为我觉得我的外表能和我的内饰相匹配。对。但我不确定。这其实很有意思，因为有时我觉得这有点像那种概念，如果我买这条裙子，我最终就会感到满足，再也不会想要一条我可以再次穿出去的短黑裙了。这就像是一种渴望的文化。存在一种渴望的文化。鲁比·斯帕克斯（Ruby Sparks）有一本关于这个的很好的书。嗯，我记不得那本书叫什么名字了。
Yeah. But it's blue. It's got a blue cover. And it's about this concept where like when she was like in the pits of despair basically, um, a stepy of wing would call it. On EG&I's favorite. The Pits of Despair. No, joking because this podcast is a favorite. The Pits of Despair, she went through a phase where she was like,
对。但它是蓝色的。它有一个蓝色的封面。它是关于这样一个概念，当她处于绝望深渊时，嗯，史黛菲·温（Stephy Wing）会这么叫它。我和 E.J. 最喜欢的。绝望深渊。开玩笑的，因为这个播客是心头好。在绝望深渊，她经历了一个阶段，当时她想，
if I get six cushions that are perfect for the couch, I will finally be good. I will finally be happy. And she spent months searching for these perfect cushions for her couch that fitted the aesthetic of her whole house. And it was going to be perfect. And she was like, yeah, that like it was never going to happen because as soon as you get those cushions, you want more. But it's this concept where she was, like, addicted to, like, find, this thing and it's actually like it's a like a psychological thing
如果我买六个适合沙发的完美靠垫，我终于就会好了。我终于会快乐了。她花了几个月的时间为她的沙发寻找这些完美的靠垫，它们要符合她整个房子的美学。一切都会完美无缺。她当时想，是的，那就像是永远不可能发生，因为一旦你有了那些靠垫，你就会想要更多。但这个概念是，她当时就像是对寻找这个东西上瘾了，这其实就像是一个心理问题。
obviously because my exercise is a little bit different but it's a psychological thing this like hunter and gathering instinct which is why like when we go shopping we feel really good for like 10 seconds and then like two weeks later we're like oh I forgot I bought that but it's actually activates the like part of your brain that has the hunter gather a
显然，因为我的锻炼有点不同，但这是一种心理问题，这种狩猎和采集的本能，这就是为什么当我们去购物时，我们会感觉好上10秒钟，然后两周后我们会说，哦，我忘了我买过那个了。但它实际上激活了你大脑中拥有狩猎采集本能的部分。
complex it's like when I gather things for my tribe my tribe will love me but I think for me personally it's like and I really do see that I think that like and I would say you know pretty well I have a very addictive personality. Goes about saying. But that's why I think
情结，就像我为我的部落收集东西时，我的部落会爱我一样。但我想对我个人而言，就像，我真的很清楚地看到，我认为，而且我想说（你知道的挺清楚），我有一种非常容易上瘾的性格。这是不言而喻的。但这就是为什么我认为
that it's like for me right now I'm like okay, if I, it's literally plastic surgery. Yeah. But it just shows how like deeply, I think it's like much more psychological. Yeah. I'm so injured psychologically by this relationship and I'm like I, if I just
对我来说，现在我就觉得，好吧，如果我，这简直就是整形手术。对。但这只是说明了它有多深，我认为这更具心理层面。对。我被这段关系在心理上伤害得如此之深，以至于我想，如果我只是
physically change my appearance so this person couldn't recognize me anymore until I could feel like myself so I could feel physically attractive. If I fundamentally change some aspect of how I looked, I finally feel like I am not, like, beholden to how this person sawed me. Yeah. Which is why self-acceptance is a good thing.
在物理上改变我的外表，这样这个人就再也认不出我了，直到我能找回自我，直到我觉得自己在生理上有吸引力。如果我从根本上改变了我外表的某个方面，我终于会觉得我不再受制于这个人看待我的方式。对。这就是为什么自我接纳是一件好事。
I've been trying that. It's not working. It doesn't do it. I think I wanted today. Because, like, I feel like, obviously, like, we're not the same person, but, like, I feel like I can relate to a level with the experience about, like, lips and stuff with Gemma. Like, I've had this whole thing.
我一直在尝试这个。不管用。根本没用。我想我今天想要。因为，就像，我觉得，很显然，我们不是同一个人，但，就像，我觉得我可以对贾玛关于嘴唇之类的经历感同身受。我经历过这一切。
like I've thought about it. I haven't gone ahead with it because I know where I'm, like, where I'm standing from is a place to please them and to please this like male gaze. But then there is that other end of it. And sorry to bring this up again. But I really want to get my hairline tattooed. But that is like for me. Yeah.
就像我想过这件事。我没有继续做下去，因为我知道我的立场是为了取悦他们，取悦这种男性的凝视。但另一方面也有另一面。抱歉又提起这个。但我真的很想去纹发际线。但那是为了我自己。对。
Like I know that's for me. It's for me. You know? Like I'm not dating. Like there's no one I'm trying to impress. I'm not trying to get laid. I'm not trying to date. I literally just feel like it would just like allow me.
就像我知道那是为了我自己。这是为了我自己。你知道吗？就像我没有在约会。就像没有人在等我留下好印象。我不是为了求爱。我不是为了约会。我只是觉得这会让我……
be more like myself. Isn't it so interesting, though, that women are at this stage where it's like to feel like myself, I fundamentally have to spend a lot of money on changing a so massive for myself. And also, what is beauty? But also, like, nothing wrong with, like, past...
更能做回自己。不过，这难道不是很奇妙吗？女性现在竟然处于这样一种阶段：为了找回自我，我从根本上必须花一大笔钱来改变一个对我而言如此巨大的外表。而且，什么是美？但是，就像，过去也没有错……
You don't just support me no matter what. Totally. And I also think that at the end of the day, like, no shame. Like, go get whatever you want done, go for it. Like... But why did you want to get them make? Well, I... I just didn't like my lips. I was like, oh, I just, you know.
无论如何你都会支持我。完全同意。而且我也认为归根结底，没有羞耻感。去做任何你想做的事，放手去做吧……但你为什么想去做呢？嗯，我……我只是不喜欢我的嘴唇。我想，哦，我只是，你知道的。
Probably because I've seen like big lips and like, oh, that, you know, that looks nice. Yeah. It looks so beautiful. Yeah, but like, you know, it's just like. No, but yeah, it is. You know, you see, I'm like, oh, you know, it's just that the ideal of beauty or whatever. Like, you know, the models or whatever. Not really, the models, but just like people, you know.
可能因为我见过丰满的嘴唇，然后想，哦，那个，你知道，看起来挺好的。对。看起来太美了。对，但就像，你知道，这就像。不，但对，确实是。你知道，你看到，我会想，哦，你知道，这只是美的理想之类。就像，你知道的，模特什么的。其实不是模特，只是人们，你知道的。
Yeah, it's a current beauty standard. Yeah, it's a current beauty standard. Like the Kardashians plucked what they wanted from like. Different cultures. Different cultures around the world. And then made that mainstream and made that consumable. and now that's like what we all are all expected to look like because women obviously all have to look at the same way.
对，这是当前的审美标准。对，这是当前的审美标准。就像卡戴珊姐妹从不同的文化中挑选她们想要的东西。来自世界各地的不同文化。然后让它成为主流，让它成为消费品。现在这就成了我们所有人都被期望长成的样子，因为很显然，女人们都必须长成同一个模子。
Yes. According to whatever trends are currently happening because God forbid we are a diverse, unique, different set of people with individual thoughts, opinions and feelings. With your hair line. But that's obviously a bit different. I don't feel like the Kardashians are. I don't feel like the Kardashians are.
是的。根据当前流行的任何趋势，因为上帝禁止我们成为一个多元的、独特的、与众不同的人群，拥有各自的思想、观点和感受。至于你的发际线。但那显然有点不同。我觉得卡戴珊姐妹不是那样的。我觉得卡戴珊姐妹不是那样的。
I don't know. Well, if we really want to go there, Gabby Hannah, do you remember her? She got her hairline done. Oh my God, Gabby now! Like years ago, and I didn't even know this was the thing. Who's Gabby Hannah? YouTuber.
我不知道。好吧，如果我们真的要说的话，加比·汉娜（Gabby Hannah），你还记得她吗？她去做了发际线。哦天哪，加比·汉娜！好几年前的事了，我甚至都不知道还有这种操作。加比·汉娜是谁？YouTuber。
YouTube. Like, yeah. She's also, I don't support her either. Anyway. No more problem about it. So, no, it was just one of the thing. So it's like the whole story. I like bleached my hair, like home bleached it in like 2020. And like if you lift up my hair, you can see just like patches of like.
YouTube博主。就像是，对。她也是，我也不支持她。不管怎样。不谈这个有争议的了。所以，不，这只是其中的一件事。就像整个故事一样。我把头发漂了，2020年的时候自己在家里漂的。如果你撩起我的头发，你能看到一块一块的……
Where the bleach was and the, like, And I'm just very aware of it because I can never wear my hair up in like high ponies anymore Because like I can see it. I just like would love to get little tattoos on it just to like make it look fuller, you know? Because I love my hair. Yeah. And it's just like I just like. Would you ever shave your head?
漂过的地方和……我对此非常敏感，因为我再也不能把头发扎成高马尾了，因为我能看到它。我只想在上面纹一点小纹发，让它看起来更饱满一点，你知道吗？因为我喜欢我的头发。对。这就像我只是想……你有没有想过剃光头？
A hundred percent would love to shave my head. Maybe we'd be talking about this all weekend. Maybe. Maybe I want to shave the head. I do because I'm sick. I've bleached my hair a couple times and I'm just sick of it. Mm-hmm. And then.
百分之百想剃光头。也许我们整个周末都在讨论这个。也许吧。也许我想剃光头。我确实想，因为我烦了。我漂过几次头发，我真的厌倦了。嗯。然后……
You're going to shave it off. Yeah, I want to get rid of it. I was thinking of dyeing it pink, like bleaching it dying at pink because I love pink. She's wearing, okay, sorry for the listeners, she's wearing full pink right now. Pink socks, pink pants, pink top, pink undies. Somewhat. Somewhat pink on these. And a beautiful, a beautiful pink blush.
你要把它剃掉。对，我想摆脱它。我考虑过把它染成粉红色，就像漂白后染成粉红色，因为我喜欢粉红色。她穿着，好吧，对听众说抱歉，她现在全身都是粉红色。粉红色的袜子，粉红色的裤子，粉红色的上衣，粉红色的内裤。差不多吧。内裤有点粉红色。还有一个漂亮的，漂亮的粉红色腮红。
Oh, you've got a pink scrunching in. Oh my gosh, she's got a pink scrunching in as well. Anyway, but yes, because I feel my hair feels just gross. I'm not happy with it, just personally. Yeah. I saw this thing that was like when you want to change a physical part of your body it's not that you want to change that
哦，你扎了个粉色的抓夹。哦天哪，她也扎了个粉色的抓夹。不管怎样，但是对的，因为我觉得我的头发看起来太糟糕了。我对自己很不满意，就我个人而言。对。我看到过这样一个说法，就好像当你想要改变身体的某一部分时，并不是你真的想改变那个
it's that you want to change something psychological about yourself you want to change something internally so it was like when you feel the inclination to like shave your head or change your hair not your head change your hair color you know get lip fillers get a nose piercing get a tattoo it's because you're going through a period of change
而是你想改变自己身上的某种心理状态，你想在内在做出改变，所以这就好像当你萌生出剃光头或者换发型——不是头，是换发色，你知道的，去丰唇、打鼻钉、纹身时，是因为你正经历一个转变期
and you want your outside to represent the internal fundamental change. Well I got my symptom done in the middle of January this year. I got the piercing. I pushed it up because we went swimming, but sorry if this is not. I like got it done and I got it in a period where I felt really out of control in my life and I wanted to take control and I just did it. And it's like I can, I was like, yeah. It was such a, it was such a big moment for me, you know? I feel like this way I got my um first tattoo in January this year and it's just quite, she's not huge but she's like, quite big for a first tattoo. Oh my god it is big for a first tattoo. Yeah, it's sizable.
而你希望你的外在能够代表内在的根本变化。嗯，我今年一月中旬做了这个。我打了这个穿孔。我把它推上去了因为我们去游泳了，但是如果这不太对的话我很抱歉。我当时就去做了，而且是在我感觉生活彻底失控、我想要夺回控制权的时候，我直接就去做了。然后就觉得，我可以，我当时就想，是的。对我来说，这是一个非常非常重大的时刻，你知道吗？我觉得今年一月我有了我的第一个纹身，它其实，它虽然不巨大，但作为一个初次纹身的图案来说已经挺大了。哦天哪，对于一个初次纹身来说确实很大。是的，它挺显眼的。
It's not it's not the biggest but it's issues up there. Um and then I like a couple months later before so interestingly this wasn't a period of change but also I kind of had planned this for a while so it's a bit different but and then I got the ones on my arms when I was leaving Hobart and they're kind of smaller ones I got three kind of smallish ones including some writing and I had such interesting conversations with people back because they were like oh I really love it blah blah blah and I was like thank you so much for affirming this because for the first time ever I felt like I was like old enough and mature enough and responsible enough to make decisions about how I wanted my body to look
它不是，它不是最大的，但也是排得上号的。嗯，然后过了几个月，所以在有趣的是，这并不完全是一个转变期，但我也差不多提前计划了一段时间，所以有点不同，然后当我离开霍巴特时，我在手臂上纹了几个，它们是那种比较小的，我搞了三个差不多小一点的，其中还包含一些文字。我和大家有过非常有趣的交流，因为他们会说，哦，我真的很喜欢它之类的话，我就说，非常感谢你们的肯定，因为这是我生平第一次觉得自己足够大、足够成熟、足够有责任感，能够为自己想要的外表做出决定
wow and it was like and I had some conversations with people are like I would never get a tattoo in my life oh my god and I was like yeah but like I actually like didn't really have any qualms about it because at the end of the day it made me feel so incredibly in control of my body I'm more in touch with my body. I'm very deeply connected to who I am as a person and like my values. This sounds really deep. It's not really that deep, but it kind of is.
哇，这就好像——我跟一些人聊过，他们说我这辈子绝不会去纹身，天哪。然后我就说，是的，但其实我对纹身没有任何顾虑，因为归根结底，它让我对自己的身体感到了无比的掌控，我与自己的身体更加紧密相连了。我与作为一个人的自我以及我的价值观有着非常深厚的联系。这听起来可能很深奥。其实没那么深奥，但某种程度上确实如此。
Like, my values and like who I am as a person and like the artwork that I like at this stage in life and like everything kind of has a certain meaning because not everybody gets tattoos with meaning but my ones to start with are with meaning because that like is what I want. And it like really, really kind of made me feel in control of my body in a way which I do not always feel.
就像我的价值观、我作为一个人的本质，以及我在人生这个阶段喜欢的艺术风格，所有这些都有着某种特定的意义，因为并不是每个人纹身都会赋予意义，但我的初衷就是为了赋予意义，因为那正是我想要的。它真的、真的让我感受到了一种对身体的掌控感，这种感觉我并不是随时都能拥有。
And now when I look at my body, I'm like, oh, I got to do that. It's mine. This is mine. Like, this is a decision I made because I can do things for myself. Yeah. And I trust myself as well. Like, when you got your tattoo, did you feel that way? Um, I got it on my 18.
现在当我看着自己的身体时，我就会想，哦，我把它纹上去了。这是我的。这是属于我的。看，这是我自己做出的决定，因为我可以为自己做主。是的。而且我也相信自己。就像，你纹身的时候，也有这种感觉吗？嗯，我18岁的时候纹的。
Wasn't that deep Meg, tell us. No, I went with my friend. I just turned out in on the day. Oh, you're mountain tattoo? Yeah, yeah. And I just went with my friend. she was going to get a bee but it was too big and we just rang up the local tattoo power in Victoria like where it was living and I was like I'll just get that little
没那么深刻吧，梅格，快告诉我们。不，我和朋友一起去的。我们当时就是临时起意。哦，你在山地纹的吗？对，对。我就和我朋友一起去了，她本来想纹一只蜜蜂，但图案太大了，于是我们就给维多利亚当地的一家纹身店打了电话，当时我就住在那里，我说我就纹那个小的
mountain and then it cost me 50 bucks yeah 50 bucks yeah woo do you know my 20 very well price if there's anyone still listening I have a tattoo dedicated to Taylor Swift and that cost me 160 dollars and you know how small it is right yeah where was no no I know oh it was it was it in Sydney it was in Sydney it was in Sydney Well, my was just a local small town. That is quite, I put... It was a really nice place though. And also, I will say this.
然后花了我50块钱，对，50块钱，哇哦！你知道我的，20岁，价格很公道。如果还有人在听的话，我有一个献给泰勒·斯威夫特的纹身，这花了我160美元，而且你知道它有多小对吧？对，在哪里？不，不，我知道，哦，是在悉尼，是在悉尼，是在悉尼。好吧，我的只是一家当地的小镇店铺。那挺，我放……不过那确实是个挺好的地方。而且，我也要说这个。
So I'm similar to Aaron in that all of my tattoos have very deep and distinct meanings for the period of my life in which I got them. And it's interesting because right now I'm in this period where I'm like, there actually isn't anything that would fully represent this for me. It's actually a good point because like the mountains. I've met a tattoo. No, so all other periods in my life I've been like, oh yeah, if someone asked me to tattoo something on my body, I'd know what I would do. because I know very, very clearly what my values are at the moment, what my kind of guiding thought and principles and life feels like. Like, you know, all my tattoos, like the ones I have on my, on my hips,
所以我和埃伦有点像，我的所有纹身对于我获得它们的那个生命阶段来说，都有着非常深刻且鲜明的意义。有趣的是，现在我正处于这样一个时期，我觉得：其实没有什么东西能完美地代表我现在的状态。这其实是个好观点，就像山脉一样。我见过一个纹身。不，我是说我生命中的其他时期，我都会想，“哦，对啊，如果有人让我把什么纹在身上，我会知道该纹什么。”因为我非常非常清楚自己目前的价值观是什么，我生命中的指导思想和原则是什么样的。就像，你知道的，我所有的纹身，比如我纹在，纹在臀部上的
on my ribs, the one I have on my back, the one I have on my hip. Yeah. All very, like, things that I really stand by. But right now, I really couldn't tell you. I couldn't, I really couldn't decide how I feel about my life right now. But when I look back at the tattoos I have gotten, especially the one
肋骨上的，后背上的，还有臀部上的。是的。所有的东西，都非常代表我真正坚守的立场。但现在，我真的说不准。我真的，真的无法决定我对现在的生活作何感想。但是当我回看我纹过的那些纹身，尤其是那个
so I have on my on my right side I have this really beautiful tree and it has an eye in it and I don't think I've told you this before but it means independence because at the time I was feeling
我在右侧肋骨纹的这个，是一棵非常漂亮的树，上面有一只眼睛，我觉得我以前可能没跟你说过，它的意思是独立，因为当时我觉得
incredibly dependent on people validation I got out of a really quite like abusive toxic relationship and it was like I really needed a reminder of myself of like I'm an independent person I can exist without the validation and the input of these people. And when I look at it, I know exactly how that felt, and I know exactly why I got it.
自己极其依赖他人的认可。我刚结束了一段非常具有虐待性、非常痛苦的关系，当时我真的很需要一个提醒，告诉自己：我是一个独立的人，没有这些人的认可和意见，我也完全可以生存下去。每当我看着它，我就清楚地知道当时是什么感觉，也清楚地知道我为什么会去纹它。
And the same with, like, some of my other ones as well. Like, I know exactly why I got them. And they're really meaningful to me because of that. But now I'm like, I actually don't know what would really define this period of my life. See, I think I have a lot of, like, art Instagrams. And I follow them. I'm like, that's so pretty. I want that on me forever. Like, I saw a really nice one today as well. And I was going through a page. And I was like, oh, my God, a tattoo ticket is only $60. does. Ooh, look at all the pretty things I could get. But interestingly, they are all at the moment. They're all women. They're all figures of women and they're all naked, mostly. The one of my back's naked. I have a naked woman on my back with like plows and stuff.
我的其他一些纹身也是如此。比如，我清楚地知道自己为什么要纹它们。正因如此，它们对我有着极其重大的意义。但现在我却觉得，我其实不知道什么才能真正定义我这段时期的生活。你看，我觉得我关注了很多艺术类的Instagram账号。我经常关注它们，然后心想：太好看了，我一辈子都想把它纹在身上。比如说，我今天也看到一个非常好看的。我当时正在浏览一个主页，然后我就想：天哪，一个纹身名额只要60美元。太棒了。噢，快看我能得到多少漂亮的东西！但有趣的是，它们目前全都是女性。全都是女性的人体，而且基本上都是赤裸的。我背上的那个就是裸体的。我背上有一个裸体女人，周围还有犁之类的东西。
And all of the ones I see, I don't know whether it's that. It makes farting. I don't know that it's the artist I follow, but all of them are like naked women. But I think it's like kind of obsession with like the female body and the female figure and like the relationship I have with that myself and how society expects women to look and I think I love the subversion of a lot of artists I follow where it's like actually we don't subscribe to the notion of like having to look I've only ever gotten tattooed by women. E.J. Would you get a tattoo? A hundred percent. I'm definitely definitely getting a tattooed. Do you get it from my friend Sydney? Yeah, 100% I really want one. So shout out to Sydney. She's a friend of the podcast, friend of the show. And she's a tattoo artist
我看到的所有这些图案，我不知道是不是因为这个。它在放屁吗？我不知道是不是因为我关注的艺术家都是这样，但它们全都是裸体女性。不过我觉得这有点像是对女性身体、女性轮廓的一种痴迷，以及我自己与这种身体的关系，还有社会对女性外表的期望。我特别喜欢我关注的许多艺术家身上那种颠覆性，就好像：事实上，我们并不认同那种必须长成特定样子的观念。我所有的纹身都是由女性纹身师完成的。E.J.你会去纹身吗？百分之百。我绝对、绝对会去纹一个。你是在我悉尼的朋友那里纹的吗？对，100%我真的很想纹一个。所以要向悉尼致敬。她是本播客的朋友，节目的朋友。她是一位纹身艺术家
and she is incredibly, incredibly talented and has given me a tattoo before. So She's in Melbourne, if anyone wants it. Sydney Ferry. An incredible, incredible artist. What's her Instagram? Sid Ferry. How do you spell that? S-Y-D-F-A-R-E-Y.
而且她非常有才华、非常有才华，之前就给我纹过身。所以如果有人想要的话，她在墨尔本。悉尼·费里（Sydney Ferry）。一位极其、极其伟大的艺术家。她的Instagram是什么？Sid Ferry。怎么拼？S-Y-D-F-A-R-E-Y。
F-A-R-E-I. I feel like they can listen back to it. E-Y. E-Y? Okay. But she's very, very talented. I really want her to give E-J-1. I really want one. So we're 44 minutes in.
F-A-R-E-I。我觉得他们可以倒回去听。E-Y。E-Y？好的。但她真的很有才华。我真的很想让她给E-J纹一个。我真的很想要一个。所以我们已经录了44分钟了
Let's do one more question. Okay. What else do we have? What's a question that we really want to ask? Oh, goodness. This is... Okay, let's... Do we want a fun question?
让我们再问一个问题。好的。我们还有什么？有什么是我们真的很想问的问题吗？哦，天哪。这个是……好吧，我们来……我们想要一个有趣的问题吗？
Do you find a reflify? question? I'm going to ask us a question. What do we want? A gem question? A gem question. Okay, let's do that. So we've had some very deep conversations, but we're going to finish off with one final question. Kind of random. But what is the one song that defines your life right now? Oh my God. What do you think it is? If you could pick one song that really encapsulates, these guys have ice cream sandwiches now. You can hear that noise. What's one song that really defines your life right now. I've got to think.
你觉得有什么能反思一下的问题吗？我要问大家一个问题。我们想要什么？一个深度问题？一个深度问题。好吧，那就这样吧。所以我们刚才进行了一些非常深刻的对话，但我们要以最后一个问题来收尾。有点随机。但哪一首歌最能定义你目前的生活？哦，天哪。你觉得会是什么？如果你能选一首歌来真正概括……这些人现在有冰淇淋三明治了。你能听到那个声音。哪首歌最能真正定义你目前的生活？我得想想。
So I actually know what it is. Go. Do you want to go, E.J.? Well, my first song that came in my head was hotel room service by Pitbull. But that is what we've been listening to all weekend. That's true. So I'm like, very happy around my friends and I feel a little love.
其实我知道是什么。说吧。你想先说吗，E.J.？嗯，我脑子里冒出的第一首歌是Pitbull的《Hotel Room Service》。但那是我们整个周末一直在听的歌。确实如此。所以我跟朋友们在一起时感到非常快乐，而且我能感受到一点爱。
So I'm going to say hotel room service. Yeah. You know? It really, it really like capitulates or represents like this experience of having a really beautiful weekend. It is, yeah. Listening to really good music. Yeah. I have one. What is it? It's this song called
所以我选《Hotel Room Service》。对吧？它真的，真的非常能够概括或代表拥有一个超级美好的周末的这种体验。确实是，对。听着非常棒的音乐。对。我有一首。是什么？是一首叫做
by Disco Lines. It's just a song I'm really like in the moment. It's called Baby Girl. Yeah. Beautiful. It's just a scattered song. It's just like chill techno music. It's not really much lyrics. It's just like really nice to listen to. And it's probably, is that in the moment. What's the vibe of the song? Is it a party song? It's very upbeat, like, yeah, yeah, pretty party song.
来自Disco Lines的歌。就是一首我当下非常喜欢的歌。它叫《Baby Girl》。对。太美妙了。这是一首很随性的歌。就像是那种很轻松的电子乐。其实没有太多歌词。就是听起来非常舒服。可能吧，就是当下的感觉。这首歌的氛围是什么？是一首派对歌吗？它很有节奏感，对，对，挺适合当派对歌的。
Like, yeah. It's like, have a good time, but they don't really know what's going on. I would say my song is Better Man by Taylor Swift Because I've been just feeling really sad And really like heartbroken And I think that song really kind of puts you in the place of Um Experiencing that and there's this song that's like You Push My Love Away like it's some kind of loaded gun
就像是，玩得开心，但又不知道到底发生了什么。我会说我的歌是泰勒·斯威夫特的《Better Man》，因为我最近一直感觉真的很伤心，而且真的很心碎。我觉得这首歌真的能把你带入那种经历痛苦的境地，里面有句歌词是“你把我的爱推开，就像一把上膛的枪”
And that really It really makes me quite sad Because I think I went through like quite a traumatic experience of like really putting myself out there and being you know very much in love with this person and getting rejected and which is hard and it's really hard and it's made me really sad and like I've really been struggling with it recently but when I listened to that song and like wow if Taylor Swift has experienced this and I'm experiencing this everything about the world just feels a little bit better and Erin what would you say your one song sorry we had a cat emergency oh what happens
这真的，这真的让我很难过，因为我觉得我经历了一段相当痛苦的经历，我全身心地投入其中，深爱着这个人却遭到了拒绝，这很难，真的很难，这让我非常难过，我最近一直在为此苦苦挣扎。但当我听到那首歌时，哇，如果泰勒·斯威夫特也经历过这些，而我也在经历这些，世界上的这一切感觉就都好受了一些。艾琳，你会说你的代表歌曲是哪一首？抱歉，我们刚才遇到了猫咪紧急情况。哦，怎么了？
No, the cat we're looking after is an outdoor cat. Boo! Yes! Outdoor cats are... No outdoor cats. No outdoor cats. Bad for the environment. But we're looking after her.
不，我们照看的那只猫是只室外猫。天哪！是的！室外猫是……不，室外猫不行。室外猫不好，对环境有害。但我们在照顾它。
And she can tell when we're about to shut her in. And so we can't walk past her in the kitchen to shut the back door because she's got like a little outdoor cat area that has a door that you have to shut. And the cat flap doesn't shut so you can't like shut the cat flap. So anyway. So you have to like go outside to shut the door But if you walk past her in the kitchen She'll run outside
而且它能看出我们什么时候想把它关在屋里。所以我们不能在厨房从它身边走过，去关后门，因为它有一个带门的户外猫活动区，你得把那个门关上。而且猫洞关不上，所以你没法把猫洞堵上。总之，你得去外面关门。但如果你在厨房从它身边走过，它就会跑出去。
So Jack and I figured out that we could walk around the back of the house To shut the door and you can like walk this giant loop around the house In the dark This is quite a big house And she's figured out what it sounds like When we're walking around the back to shut the door So she runs away So you can't like trap her in the house at night
所以杰克和我发现，我们可以绕到房子后面去关门，你可以沿着房子在黑暗中走这么一大圈。这房子挺大的。它已经摸清了我们绕到后面去关门时发出的声音是什么样的，所以它会跑开，这样你就没法把它困在屋里过夜了。
Which is like really really bad Because cats 100% need to come inside When it gets dark So Jack was like, yeah, don't know what to do. So she escaped. So she escaped, basically. But it's why she's an outdoor cat, so she comes back. But it's just so annoying.
这真的很糟糕，因为猫在天黑时100%需要进屋。所以杰克就说，唉，不知道该怎么办。于是它逃跑了。所以基本上它逃跑了。但这就是为什么它是室外猫，所以它会回来的。但这真的很烦人。
Like, why can't she just? But Erin, what's your song? What's your song represents your life? So mine was Better Man by Taylor Swift. Nakes was Baby Girl by Disco Lines. And EJ's was hotel room service by Pitbull. Okay, wait, let me go through. Oh, me and the hotel room.
就像，它为什么就不能……但是艾琳，你的歌是什么？哪首歌能代表你的生活？我的代表作是泰勒·斯威夫特的《Better Man》，内克斯的是迪斯科莱恩斯的《Baby Girl》，EJ的是皮普保罗的《Hotel Room Service》。好吧，等等，让我想想。哦，我和酒店房间。
You can bring your friend. So I feel like it's really sad because it makes us like this upbeat tempo Oh, I actually have a really nice song that at the moment I'm really liking. Actually, can I have two? Yes, go for it.
你可以带你的朋友来。所以我觉得这真的很伤感，因为它让我们……节奏这么欢快。哦，我其实有一首非常喜欢的歌，目前我很喜欢。其实，我可以选两首吗？可以，去吧。
Okay. So my first one is something called the Uggam-Bugam song by Brenton Wood. I'm so sad. Mine is so sad. So much joy. Do you want to?
好。所以我的第一首是一首叫布伦顿·伍德的《The Uggam-Bugam Song》。我太难过了。我的歌太伤人了。充满了快乐。你想……？
Can I play a short clip? I can't play a shortcut? They have to go out. Can I sing it? Oh. No, I'll play it. Let's see you guys later. It's joyful.
我可以放一小段吗？我不能放快捷键吗？它们得出去。我可以唱吗？哦。不，我来放。回头见啦，伙计们。这首歌充满欢乐。
It's pure joy in a song. It's fantastic. And it makes me feel happy every time I hear it. So if you're having a bad day, listen to the Ogum-Buggin' song by Brenton Wood. And it is truly, truly. What's the other one, Aaron? Okay, the other song.
这是一首纯粹充满快乐的歌。太棒了。每次听到它，我都觉得很开心。所以如果你今天过得不开心，去听听布伦顿·伍德的《Ogum-Buggin' Song》吧。这首歌真的，真的……另一首是什么，艾琳？好的，另一首歌。
The other song is called To Be in Love with Yourself by Bobby Boyd. Okay, I actually like that. And it's beautiful. It's like, I don't know what era it's from. Let's have a look on Spotify. But we should listen to both of these songs. You should listen to both of these songs because this one is really beautiful. And it's just this guy singing about like, and it literally just goes to be in love with yourself.
另一首歌叫《To Be in Love with Yourself》，作者是博比·博伊德。好的，我其实挺喜欢这首的。这歌太美了。它就像……我不知道它是哪个年代的。我们在Spotify上查一下吧。不过我们应该听听这两首歌。你们应该听听这两首歌，因为这首真的非常美。而且就是这个家伙在唱歌，歌词大概是……字面意思就是“爱你自己”。
Can I read up the lyrics for a little bit? It's okay. So Aaron's on a real self-love journey. It's really... She's also on a real podcast tangent journey in which she needs to read out the lyrics. No, I need to. Okay. Because I need you all to listen to these beautiful words.
我可以朗读一小段歌词吗？没关系。所以艾琳正在经历真正的自爱之旅。她也正经历着真正的播客题外话之旅，在这个过程中她需要读出歌词。不，我需要。好吧。因为我需要你们所有人都听听这些美妙的词句。
We're going to be here for them. You're not. You're not. My first. sliding. Sorry. That is a very beautiful song. You're going to cut the service out.
我们会一直陪着它们的。你不会。你不会。我的第一首。滑动。抱歉。那真是一首非常美妙的歌。你要把服务切断了。
I'm not going to cut the service out. It's going to be fine. I'm literally Googling things. It's all good. Oh, there's like not even that many lyrics out there because it's quite an old song. So what are the lyrics?
我不会切断服务的。没问题的。我正在用谷歌搜索呢。一切都好。哦，上面甚至没有那么多歌词，因为这是一首挺老的歌。那歌词是什么？
Okay, I'm trying to try to load. We really want to know what the lyrics are. Sonychitz.com. Load my lyrics. Okay, these are absolutely not the right lyrics. Okay, well, how about you just like. But it basically just goes to me in love with yourself. And it's really beautiful.
好吧，我正在试着加载。我们真的很想知道歌词是什么。Sonychitz.com。加载我的歌词。好吧，这些绝对不是正确的歌词。好吧，要不你就……但它基本上就是“爱你自己”。这首歌真的很美。
And the lyrics make me want to cry every time, it's like sometimes it's like hard and sometimes it's easy and he just like sings about all these these things and I think he's singing to a girl about how good it is to be in love with you so because he like sings a girl in the song but yeah okay actually that was a really that was a lot beautiful more beautiful than if we'd heard the lyrics okay no no no really really sweet way I'm glad that you explained it that way yeah well I'd like to thank my beautiful guess oh was that our last question it was no wonder Meg was trying to hurry me along well I would like to thank you guys coming on and um yeah welcome to the first episode of Girl Talks and if you
而且每次听到这歌词我都想哭，就好像有时候生活很艰难，有时候又很简单，他就在歌里唱到所有这些事情，我觉得他是在对一个女孩唱，唱着爱上你是多么美好的一件事，因为他在歌里对一个女孩唱歌，但是，好吧，其实那真的很……那比我们听到歌词要美好得多。好吧，真的，真的很温馨的方式，我很高兴你用这种方式解释了它。是的，我要感谢我的美丽嘉宾。哦，那是我们最后一个问题吗？是的，难怪梅格刚才一直催我快点。好吧，我要感谢你们来参加节目，嗯，欢迎收看《Girl Talks》的第一期，如果你
liked it, subscribe, give us a rating you know the deal. Follow us on Instagram Yeah. I hope you enjoyed it. Did you guys enjoy it? Leave it with you. Yes. Five stars. Please. I hope that you guys will have nothing left. I will. I've rated it at five. I haven't written no video. I didn't realize that you could rate things
喜欢的话，请订阅，给我们打个分，你知道怎么做。关注我们的Instagram。希望你们会喜欢。你们喜欢吗？留给你们了。是的。五星好评。拜托。希望你们不会留下任何遗憾。我会的。我给打了五星。我没有写任何文字。我没意识到你可以在Spotify上打分。
on Spotify. You can. Yeah. So Meg better get on it. So that was only a recent thing that you could rate stuff on Spotify. Yeah, it's very recent. So you guys better fucking get on it and thank you for listening and thank you guys for the vulnerable chats. This has been a slightly useful conversation. Who cares if it isn't? We're going to be able to listen back to this.
你可以的。是的。所以梅格最好去弄一下。所以这只是最近才有的功能，你可以在Spotify上给内容打分。是的，这是最近才有的。所以你们最好赶紧去弄，谢谢你们的收听，也谢谢你们进行走心的聊天。这是一次稍微有点用的谈话。谁在乎有没有用呢？我们以后还能回听这个节目。
We'll listen to it, but hopefully you, the listener, have made it to the end and have enjoyed it. I love every time you say thank you for listening to the end because I always listen to the end. Do you listen to the end, E.J.? I do. I can show you. I have true. No, but it's really lovely because whenever you say that, it makes me really happy. Because it's probably just you and E. Because it's probably just me and E.
我们会回听的，但希望你，亲爱的听众，已经坚持听到了最后并且喜欢它。我每次听到你谢谢大家坚持听到最后我都好喜欢，因为我总是会听到最后。EJ，你听到最后吗？我听的。我可以向你证明。我真的听了。不，这真的很棒，因为每当你这么说的时候，都会让我感到非常开心。因为可能只有你和E。因为可能只有我和E。
PJ listening to the end of the episode. My mom doesn't even listen to the end. My mom doesn't have time to listen to my podcast. No, I love your mom. But thank you so much for listening and we'll see you guys next time. Hey, what's good y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere,
PJ听到了单集的最后。我妈甚至都不听结尾。我妈没时间听我的播客。不，我很爱你的妈妈。但非常感谢大家的收听，我们下期再见。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人群体的经历，进行着那些在其他地方绝对算不上安全的坦诚对话，
but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be playing. not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的持牌专业人士进行交流。有多少男人披着一副盔甲？它向世界释放出的信号是：你可不是好惹的。仅仅因为你拥有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。请在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships. And you will. come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
让自己经受一些磨难。你将会在另一侧，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己。请在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。那是“TWO percent”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定亲自动手。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他将罪有应得。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝，在IHeartRadio应用、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。这是一个IHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。